e
e e
let's
get good morning everyone um just going
to open up our meeting uh
today U for the special committee on
covid um we are a bipartisan committee
that is tasked with investigating and
evaluating the state's response to the
covid-19
pandemic the committee will function in
a science-based fact finding review
specifically acquiring comprehensive
accurate data and all information
related pertaining there to areas of
particular Focus will include the
administration of federal guidance
acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued outlining the
committee's findings and the impact on
New
Hampshire um I would ask that uh
represent po off uh lead us in the
pledge
please Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all um I would like to thank everyone
for being here I know the weather
was not
ideal but I don't know if we've had
ideal weather for the last few
weeks um but anyways uh director Buxton
who was originally supposed to be here
this morning uh has uh sent an email
uh around
215 yesterday afternoon saying that he
had a schedule change and could not
attend this
morning um we do have somebody coming in
to talk to us uh but they've also got
delayed due to weather uh as well
as uh some other
detours um but I guess I would take this
time and ask the committee members if
there's anything specific
specific um that we would like to
address to director
buckon uh and we could send him an email
so that when he does come in he has
information in front of us and I will
defer to the
committee representative
Belcher thank you madam chair I I think
what we would like or what I'd like to
see done is to outline um perhaps in the
same manner that we've previously
proceeded in a sort of time timeline
sort of manner the uh specific actions
um taken uh by DHHS so actions taken um
especially significant actions taken the
guidance even even if it wasn't mandates
but guidance put out um as well as uh
significant actions receive or I suppose
you could say orders received from any
any federal authorities or or anyone
else for that matter matter as well as
guidance received from any federal
authorities or anyone else for that
matter um that would be my
recommendation and I think maybe we
narrow those down to what kind of things
because we we could we could be swamped
with data so what kind of things do we
consider significant that we would like
to see as a part of
that anyone else repres
gr thank you madam chair so at the
beginning of this meeting the very very
the first um meetings of this commit
commiss committee we specifically wanted
to see and hear from the director of
Homeland Security based on
what we had heard so I think we should
go back to do we have minutes of that
meeting and go back because all that was
outlined we talked about that in I think
it was the first or second meeting it
was the meeting when when director uh
till Tilly came right in directed uh uh
Tilly uh she had given us
[Music]
um the guidance and she had outlined
given us an outline of the co response
from
DHHS
um D yes so we we do have that outline
um and when I did correspond with
director buckson I told him that that
we're also interested in if he
could when he meets with us give us kind
of an idea of what their report is going
to
contain um because I think that is also
important um that we understand what
their focus was um because as we even in
our mission there is so many areas of
focus that we could go down
that the hopes to have him in was
to not
um try and be
duplicative
um but we'll have to wait and see uh yes
representative evil well unfortunately I
don't have the uh list in front of me
but I it seems like we got something at
some point may I thought it was from
um uh director Tilly that said the
different subjects that the home land
security report was going to cover
and I guess uh my thought would be that
we look at that list I remember uh
Health was one of them but we could look
at the list and then maybe zero in on
those particular aspects of it when he
he comes in but I agree with you one of
the big things I'd like to hear from him
is just maybe an overarching um uh
summary of what they're doing and what
their timeline is for uh producing their
report and then at some point level we
can kind of figure out what we're doing
that might be additive or duplicative to
their uh
work right and and I will forward
another email and I will ask for it to
be printed out um but I also have here
and I was hoping I with everything else
going on I apologize for this but I'll
get this printed sent this off upstairs
but this is a covid-19 vaccine roll out
um and how that followed um and it talks
about the the actual roll out um when uh
on March 3rd in 2020 there was uh a
declaration of Public Health incident
March 13th the governor declared the
state of
emergency um March 23rd the first covid
death happened um and the 100th covid-19
case was reported in New Hampshire um I
will send this off to H uh house
committee Services now and ask that they
uh see if they can print these out for
us but it talk but this is all about the
actual vaccine roll out um it up until
and it goes through even through to
October
2023 the FDA authorizes the emergency
use of the updated novavax covid-19
vaccine and amends the eua to include
individuals over the age of 12 um and
when I read that and I listen to Dr korf
um I have some concerns based on some of
the testimony that we've received um
about the ages of the vaccines based on
what he was given guidance
I don't know how anybody else on this
committee feels about that or or what
their thoughts are
um so I'm hoping that at some point we
can find out the science behind the
vaccines
and I'll just leave it at that does
anybody else have anything else uh that
they would like to talk discuss
um so I was gonna so who prepared that U
your P nope um um Patricia Tilly yes
okay um yeah I mean because she DHHS or
Ben Chan we who we've talked about
having come in here um seems like they
would be the uh appropriate people to
have that kind of a
conversation um I mean as I look at our
mission I think the particular focus is
Health but the other thing is the money
flows and for that reason that's why I
think it would be really useful to have
Taylor Caswell come in or whoever he
might like to designate to just talk
about the federal funds I think that's
something really really worthwhile
investigating because it's something
largely the legislature wasn't a
participant in um so that that's uh one
thing and I I don't know how much of
that aspect the homeland security
director is focusing
on and represent evil I 100% agree with
you and I I uh like I said it would be I
think we would gain a lot of insight um
from uh director Caswell or commissioner
Caswell um coming in here and
understanding
um how all the money's flowed
um not only you
know how it was handled at the um the
agencies but how it the agencies
actually divested some of that uh those
dollars and do they still have those
dollars and are they still utilizing
them and if they do what are they using
them for and is it is it in the best
interest
um of the public uh the way that they're
using them I mean I was concerned to
find out that uh schools were
opting to fix things versus air
filtration I mean because to me a good
air filtration in a school Not only
would benefit you know during the co
time but during any time where we have
increases like with the flu and
everything everything else would help
mitigate and keep students healthy um so
that I think is is a huge area of
concern of mine so so I'm just thinking
in terms of questions I don't know who
to ask the question of but the but the
uh Federal funding roll out a timeline
would be really interesting I mean we've
got the covid roll out and the different
you know orders that were issued but be
interested
to get a timeline of the federal fund
distribution and maybe overlay that with
the with the health roll out and uh we
could ask the homeland
security uh director I forget his name
but maybe Taylor could help us with that
too I mean I think that's a worthwhile
thing to look at uh because I'm not sure
who has honestly I I I don't know right
uh representative
us and along those lines what money came
in for the
schools specifically for covid response
and what did they do with it what did it
actually get spent on and how much is
still hanging around represent Belcher
thank you madam chair so just listening
to what we've been talking about I I
wholly agree with that and all of that
um all those lines of questioning I also
want to uh look at um well for instance
when it comes to uh treatments such as a
vaccine I think those are questions we
want to put to DHS and if they had no
hand in it that's not their purview that
would be excellent information to have
because that means we no longer have to
pursue that line of questioning with
them we can directed elsewhere I also
would like to look at lines of
questioning around things like um what
is variously described as either
shutdowns or stay-at-home orders um
essential Personnel decisions business
and house of worship closers guidance
the science behind it the legal
Authority behind it what analysis legal
analysis was done and who was that legal
analysis done by was the guidance coming
from the federal level uh supernational
level was it coming from the state level
who in particular was it coming from
that might give us guidance for who we
might ask to come in or present further
questions uh to on these specific topics
Federal funding um obviously uh tracing
that money the timeline
whether there were and what uh any
requirements attached to that funding
and what they were for instance uh did
any of these federal funds require the
state to have certain uh to make
vaccines or monocon antibodies available
and how did were there any requirements
on that uh for specific rollouts uh or
or lockdowns or closures or anything
else required coming with that Federal
funding so these are all questions that
I think we can we can reasonably put
together and put forward and again if
the if the answer from DHS is that's not
our purview we didn't have a hand in it
awesome now we can move on and and and
direct them elsewhere represent
leas yes I was looking back at my notes
and um one of the things
I interested in is where and how they
got their data to make the decisions
they made because we kept getting
information um and we kept you walk into
any place with the TV on and there'd be
scroll you know waiting for the doctor's
office whatever scrolling announcements
and I'm wondering where they got the
data and how they made the decisions as
to what to put out um I have a quote
from them we knew our data was bad but
they kept putting out
information even though they knew the
data was bad so the question is where
were they getting their data and how
were they making those decisions to put
those announcements out when they knew
their data was
bad represent
POF thank you Madame chair
um um I don't have a specific question
but uh I wonder like um in regular times
our medicine is run by medical
professionals with some input from
scientists and some input with local
policy
makers and then we switch to times when
a lot of it is run by military and
agencies like Homeland Security so I
wonder what kind of lessons we learned
from that is a is military and Homeland
Security the best equipped to run
our medicine or part of it and uh is
there any better interaction between
science scientists for example and those
implementing uh in agencies those
medical decisions could be made in
future in case if we need to involve
them again and in my
view uh we we all often hear about uh
science has changed so our knowledge
evolves
and in order to implement the best
decision we need discussion we need some
uh some variety of opinions but when we
have some kind of militarized response
with a simple task to be achieved the
tendency is to do the opposite is to
shut down all the discussions and just
to follow the goal that was initially
set and that might be one of the line of
questioning we want to ask how we should
do it differently next time
uh and I I I like your where you're
going there but I think we have to have
uh director of Homeland Security in here
to really understand some part of that
question thank you represent evil I mean
I think part of the challenge here is
that Homeland Security is actually
assessing everything that we're talking
about and their report isn't going to be
done until the end of June so we'll just
you know who knows what they'll be able
to say when they're here
I just would uh encourage us that when
we're putting together questions that we
keep it to a very limited number
otherwise it becomes I think really
overwhelming for the agency I mean we
can't send and I'm not saying anybody
was suggesting that we are but we can't
send them pages and pages and pages of
questions because at that rate we're
going to get less I think you know less
is Le it so we need to be careful of of
the magnitude of what we're asking and
and and be pretty
focused okay um I believe we have
someone from the public here uh that
would like to speak to us
uh are you you yeah uh please have a
seat uh introduce yourself
and
absolutely
e e
please introduce yourself uh where
you're from and what you like to discuss
with our
committee it's red Now red means go okay
all right that's a New Hampshire
thing sorry just
kidding all right my name is John Bodwin
I live in Massachusetts I grew up in
Connecticut and I plan to move to New
Hampshire I started a company in New
Hampshire
recently uh these were printed in LEL
Massachusetts but they're distributed by
pathway book service in New Hampshire uh
it's one of one of your companies a very
good company I would highly recommend
them um
I'm one of very few people in the world
that has uh more than a million
non-reacted um death
records that have been analyzed I've
been looking at them for almost two
years now actually over two years it's
uh it's April so over two years and from
that I was able to glean certain things
that no one really can from the CDC data
which isn't really the cdc's data it's a
compilation of all states that send
their data to the CDC
in fact the only way to track uh causes
of death well before I get into it I'm
an engineer I have an MBA I um
electrical engineering my career was in
sales of large contracts so to get an
idea about what I did in my career I
would meet with um well it started out
Engineers when I was young and by the
time I I don't want to say retired but I
I was done with that uh career I was
meeting with CEOs CFOs CT
of multi-billion dollar
corporations um I'll just go to the one
of the big deals I put together which
was the guidance control system for the
Trident nuclear missile MK6 Le which is
the Polaris nuclear missile that pops
out of
submarines uh the guidance control
system looks like a basketball it sits
in a nose cone and um the companies
let's see Ron northrip no northr wasn't
in that one the prime contractor was
Draper with whom I negotiated the
contract and uh put all pieces together
but they talked to Ron in elsag gundo
California not locally also General
Dynamics in Pittsfield crane naval base
in Indiana Honeywell in Florida and in I
think their Fab was in the it was in the
midwest maybe Minnesota so in in putting
all these deals together for multiple
sites multiple Engineers um Executives
and very big corporations I'll cut to
the Chase and say that's that's netted
over a billion dollars in revenue for
the company I represented I was told not
to work on it but I did it anyway and I
think they're pretty happy about that so
um in putting all these deals together
they put $40,000 of training into me
which is kind of like an MBA over over
years and it's it's how to speak to
people do public speaking as well as how
to negotiate but also how
to I don't want to say manipulate but um
how to get people to uh understand what
you're trying to sell and it's nothing
to do with what I'm trying to sell and
I'm trying to say it's really what you
want to hear and what's important to you
and so it's to bring the value of the
information to the person who's
listening which is what I'm here to do
today uh so that was my career and
because of that I speak well I interface
with people well and um I can also
investigate I also have my engineering
skills I understand the physical world
um I understand well
science that people don't understand
what science is it's very long process
uh engineering is is not you work on a
schedule the product has to work it has
to be safe and it has to make money if
it doesn't make money you don't get a
job as an engineer right the company
goes out of business science they get
grants they have to beg the government
for Grants um they hope that their baby
their thesis their hypothesis um has
enough evidence behind it after maybe 10
20 years um and they they don't really
really uh they should not be relied upon
is what I'm saying so I have a lot to
say and I'm going to get into the data
uh call it data but these are really
people every data point is a person
every pixel and every graph are people
who died and these are excess people who
died that should not have died and they
did not die from covid they died from
government
interventions so I'll say right now I'm
here as a journalist um I write under
the name kand which means or Ina kand um
little different accent up there it
means um bad dog I like Elgato Malo from
uh Twitter and that's Spanish for the
bad cat so I'm French and I'm the bad
dog and as a
journalist um there are certain
whistleblowers who have come to me with
government data I'm going to re review
that first before I get into the data I
have officially and publicly
so the following information regarding
the deaths of New Hampshire citizens um
should not have been hidden from the
people the people need to know in order
to make an informed decision whether or
not they should take a countermeasure as
they call it or they've renamed it a
vaccine which isn't really what it was
but they changed the definition of
vaccine I'm sure you guys know that in
order to call this a
vaccine uh the data belongs to the
people not the government identif
ification need not be known for the
people to know the results what that
means is
um
you your HHS Department should be
providing this information it doesn't
have to be identities they always hide
behind the oh uh we can't identify them
because of Privacy Law well the privacy
laws are different in Death than they
are in life and hipa does not apply but
uh there's no reason why they can't give
you the data as to how many people died
the day of the day after two days after
vaccination so at least 87 people died
in New Hampshire within 3 days of covid
immunization at least 50 died within two
days of covid immunization in New
Hampshire at least 24 died the day of or
the day after the following 11 people
and I'll only use their first names out
of respect because I did testify at
another hearing and I was told um not to
use the last name so I'll honor that so
the following 11 people died on the same
day of covid immunization Rodney was 62
years old died March 29 2022 Barbara 68
years old died January 5 2021 Amy
72 October 28
2021 Daniel
76 May 28 2021 that that's four in
2021 we should have known then that was
four years ago excuse me three years ago
three years ago there was enough data to
shut this down V's vaccine aders event
Reporting System I looked at that in
February of
2021 there was enough information in
four weeks of January to shut the
vaccine down but it was all hidden and
suppressed um an was 77 May 18 2022
Louise Fontaine 81 June 22 2021
margarite was 83 years old died January
29 2021 Roger died May 30 2021 Katherine
84 years old died January 9 2021 Sheila
died January 31 2021 Edward January 18
2021 he was 93 these 11 died on the same
day of covid immunization in New
Hampshire these are your
people since this is a a broad-based
covid uh response efficacy hearing I I
want to go back to the mask mandate and
alert you to certain facts you probably
don't know very few people know unless
you read um my
articles I'm going to submit this I
don't have multiple copies I'm just
going to read a little bit from it I
won't spend too much time on masks
people don't want to hear about it but
it's going to happen again if you don't
understand what really happened
so um I sued Governor Charlie Baker and
the public health commissioner in
Massachusetts in the US District Court
District of Massachusetts um case 1 20-
cv-11 one87
dnmg that was over order 31 in
Massachusetts this the co emergency
orders I sued on the basis of I'm deaf
in one ear and he violated my
constitutional rights because I could
not receive free speech from others
because I could not hear them without
seeing their lips move so by ordering
other people to cover their mouths he
deprived me of receiving free speech
that was the legal Theory I
used they rescinded the governor
rescinded order 31 and issued order 55
and in order 55 in paragraph 2B there is
an exception the exception is people
hearing impaired and people speaking to
anybody hearing impaired don't have to
wear a mask and by doing so he took my
standing I'll get into standing later
it's probably something the the house
members should consider in changing the
rules of civil procedure of New
Hampshire so that cases don't get kicked
out of court and people's uh most
foundational uh rights are not violated
that is to the right to petition the
government for redress grievances but
sticking to the mask issue for a moment
and how it relates to New
Hampshire let me let me go on on that
um so the case was dismissed because I
didn't have standing but my public
records request came in the day the case
was dismissed and I got 1,200 pages and
if you remember the news in 2020 how
Massachusetts oh what a major coup they
got um 1.4 or 1.7 million masks from
China flown in on the New England
Patriots jet everybody remember
that okay well they they contracted with
Professor Gregory rled at MIT to test
those masks I have the internal emails
from the Massachusetts Department of
Public Health he tested the masks and on
April 20th 2020 he reported back to the
Massachusetts Department of Public
Health they don't
work they knew then they don't
work it's supposed to be 95%
efficacy they were at 38 42 they got up
to 80 in one batch but most of them were
around 50% which makes them basically
useless and that's across a test fixture
not a person's mouth with zero
leaks if you have a perfect fit there
are also instructions in this article
this is all internal emails from the
Department of Public Health he knew on
April 20th 2020 before he issued the
mask mandate like every governor in
every state issued some mask Mandate of
some type except I believe South
Dakota um and I think FL it depends on
the state some states go by County they
have County rules um but you had a broad
sweeping everybody doing masks and
fouchy saying you heard him say ah they
don't really do anything until somebody
got to him and said no no no we need to
coers people into getting the vaccine so
make them more masks until they get the
vaccine so
there is
a an attorney in in New Hampshire who
took on the governor of New Hampshire
for parents who didn't want their kids
masked in
schools
well the the bar of New Hampshire went
back in his past found something and uh
basically attacked him and they
suspended his license to practice for
two years on the way out of the meeting
I said hey what did they say to you now
of course this is here say but this
isn't the court well they just asked me
how the case was going against the
governor like yeah you were sent a
message if you go against the government
for anything like a mask on a child
where they're fidgeting with it it does
nothing in fact it does the opposite
because Cassidy baraca was seven years
old and she died with fungal and
bacterial puracy she didn't die from
that she died from the vaccine she
reacted in five minutes threw up for8 to
10 hours and they gave her another one a
couple weeks
later and she died terrible stomach pain
agonizing she was dead in five days but
she died with fungal and bacterial
puracy
why if if you understand material
properties and you understand fluid
dynamics then breathing into something
on your face is like wearing a petri
dish for six to eight hours all day it
makes no sense at all it's a warm moist
environment now viruses can't replicate
without a host but bacteria and fungi do
and they did you you not only breathe
them in you replicate them multiply them
in the mask and then when you breathe in
they go deeper into your lungs because
they're smaller particles and they
deposit deeper so with regard to um
covid measures you should look into why
the mask mandate
occurred and why did education
departments then require students to
wear masks and in the same uh what they
call an order which isn't in order
because they generally don't have the
authority to do
that give you an example in
Massachusetts um they said if the class
gets if the school gets to 80%
vaccination rate then you don't have to
wear a
mask what does that have to do with the
trying to protect people it's clearly a
carrot and stick these rules that came
out and and check the rules in New
Hampshire
I I I'm friends with one of the uh
litigants one of the plaintiffs in the
case um and she she lived in Brook the
Brookline um Hollis school
district and as since left the state
like many people because they don't want
their kids being abused by mandates that
do nothing except coers people to get a
vaccine that's
dangerous there was other coercion
coercion of doctors you need to look
into excuse me the American Board of
internal medicine American Board of
Family Medicine American Board of
Pediatrics put out a joint statement to
all doctors in the
country and this was based on the
Federation of State Medical
boards now that that sounds like an
official organization right the
Federation of State Medical boards it's
a nonprofit non-governmental
organization with a ton of power they
think they regulate everything licensing
and everything
else go look at who their executives are
it's on the um it's on the web look at
the board of directors they're more
concerned about Dei than they are
concerned about making sure doctors are
qualified to practice medicine and when
you have a centralization of authority
like that they re tyranny down on the
people and what you have as lwes at the
margins I I I'll try not to talk too
economic focused um and people I'm told
I speak above U certain people when I do
that but so the Federation of State
Medical boards
Well here here's the uh I'll I'll submit
this as well this was September 9 2021
the Federation of State Medical boards
which supports its member states member
State Medical licensing boards has
recently issued a statement it sounds
like they're in charge of supporting
your medical licensing board but they
shouldn't be they're just another
organization they're a RICO
organization so saying that providing
misinformation about the covid-19
vaccine contradicts Physicians ethical
and professional
responsibilities they're telling
Physicians they they can't say anything
that they consider
misinformation and therefore may be
subject to physician disciplinary
actions including suspension or rication
of their medical license they're
threatening publicly still on the web
today every single doctor in this
country that if they don't comply if
they don't shut up and they don't give
them the guidelines as to what's
information misinformation or
information or
disinformation they're now in charge of
your State Licensing Board if I were a
resident in New Hampshire I'd be pretty
upset some group down in Texas that's
getting a ton of money from various
organizations is telling your medical
board what to
do uh we are the American Board of
Family Medicine American Board of
internal medicine American Board of
Pediatrics and we support the fsmb's
position so this this joint statement is
from the CEOs of those three medical
boards now if you don't know the
difference so State Licensing boards are
for licensing your doctors but the board
certifications those are kind of NGO
organizations that certify doctors so
that they can say operate in a hospital
because a hospital for insurance reasons
won't let um a
doctor they'll take away privileges to
use the hospital which they need to use
right so board certification is very
important to doctors in order to be able
to function in their in their
purview um and they go on we also want
Physicians certified by our boards to
know that such unethical or
unprofessional conduct may prompt their
respective
board to be take to take action that
could put their certification at risk
another
threat this is the society we live in
where the doctors you go to are
threatened by their boards and are
making making decisions for their own
best interest and not
yours I'll submit that as well the
FSNB uh spreading covid vaccine
information so this is directly from the
S FSNB that's referred to by the CEOs of
those
boards um I'm not sure if you're
familiar with Rico crime uh the elements
of a RICO crime it has to be an
Enterprise that's two or more entities
in most jurisdictions sometimes it's
three or more depends on the
jurisdiction that you're in this being
Federal uh two or more entities I just
read you3 and four if you include the
FSNB um it has to be a pattern now
pattern means again different things in
different jurisdictions but in most
cases it's at least two times so they
have to have committed that illegal
activity at least twice of racketeering
activity and the racketeering activity
are it's a list of predicate crimes
crimes of which fraud murder and such
can be uh part of it and I will get into
that so the these organizations relating
to each other and communicating with
each other especially with um exhibit H
in the CDC memorandum that I handed to
you you don't have to look now but um if
you look at that you'll see America
First legal Steven Miller is associated
with that organization they did a state
they did a Foya a federal um Foya not a
state one for hhs.gov and received
information and in that information you
will see that hhs.gov
CDC and others uh from the US government
conspired with people from Facebook and
Twitter they have an open portal they
communicate as to what information they
want taken
down so whatever citizens post the
government our government and the the
centralized government in Washington DC
is telling you what you can or cannot
say what they deem misinformation even
if it's not misinformation if they don't
like it they want it down they have
people suspended they have people they
had people embedded in Twitter you know
that you know that that you know if they
weren't getting their check directly
from FBI they were still taking orders
and their check was coming from Twitter
or
Facebook so the fsmb uh like I said
they're basically impersonating a
federal agency as a it's a nonprofit
Federation not a federal entity State
Licensing boards bow down to a woke
entity out of Houston Texas run by
oligarchs every board and every group is
captured and they Co they use coercion
solicitation to get doctors and Hospital
administrators to to do their bidding if
youve if you interview certain doctors
you'll learn what I learned directly and
why they left Massachusetts or another
state that pushes the uh the drugs
um one was a
40-year-old came in with 95%
oxygen he was told he had to by the
hospital Administration staff he had to
put them on a
ventilator why well the doctors were
told that if you don't put somebody on a
ventilator and you only put them on a
CPAP you don't contain the aerosols to
the patient a CPAP will allow the
aerosols to go into the
room and the staff is going to die the
nurses the doctor
they're going to
die
so that's what they did they took people
with no problem with oxygen and they put
them on
ventilators now why did the
administrators of hospitals tell the
doctors to do this was it because they
really believed about the aerosol
problem or was it because the car act
and other legislation at DC level in and
I heard you talking earlier about the
money it incentivizes people put putting
on being put on
ventilators there are a few things that
are incentivized one is putting covid
diagnosis on a death record or um a
patient record they get money for
that using ventilators they get money
for that there's a drug called REM
Desir if you don't mind me asking um do
you have documentation that shows that
they're being incentivized
just out of curiosity if if I might I I
don't mean to interrupt but if I might I
that was actually in the documentation I
read into the record of the last
meeting thank you
representative there we go um direct
accounting files no that's like the Holy
Grail of evidence nobody has but I I can
go on the web and I can look at cms.gov
okay you go to cms.gov and look for
nctap that's a covid payout plan and
you'll find that aluman uh which is
baricitinib or vlar which is remes has a
20% Adder to the entire hospital bill if
if if somebody goes in with a I'll get
to examples in a little bit you're going
to see when I get to the real evidence
um you'll see what I mean it's it's it's
bad they they murdered a lot of
people more than a million
people so the car's act I went through
um is basically a solicitation of fraud
um Walter E Williams said it but
probably also said by Thomas soul Milton
Friedman if you subsidize something
you'll get more of it and since they
subsidized Co being put on a death
certificate thinking somehow or
convincing the people that that's going
to save
people how is that going to save
somebody but that's what they did uh
people being put on ventilators that's
an 86% kill
rate 86% of people
get put on
ventilators and they did it to people
who whose vital signs were
normal and they
died I'll tell you about 28-year-old
Danielle so 18 USC 1035 is false
statements on Healthcare matters 1040 is
fraud and disaster relief 1343 is fraud
by wire 241 is conspiracy against rights
242 is deprivation of rights under color
of law those are just five there's a lot
more and they carry five to 20 years
sometimes more and they add up because
they did all these things plus murder um
they're doing this as a matter of custom
and practice in almost every um medical
examiner office and I say that by
extrapolating the data that I have
across other states I know that they've
been writing things on death
certificates that are not true I also
know that the CDC has been deleting
vaccine as a cause of death which I will
show you evidence of that's in the CDC
memorandum paragraphs 49 through
51 so New Hampshire deaths in
Massachusetts and Connecticut if you
open the books there are some loose um
papers in
front I'll try to go through these
quickly
um this is public these are obituaries
online so uh Rick Rick Morris he died of
a heart attack in his
sleep March 5th 2024 at age
64 I know that he was vaccinated because
the it correlated to the only record
available in in vs for that person um
with all those details of death and so
he was vaccinated on January 25th that's
days um it should be
investigated if if this be's ID really
is him then he died in 40 days after
Gene drug
injection on March 5th
2024 people are still getting the
vaccine excuse me on January 25th
2024 people are still taking these shots
because the government and state
governments are telling them to and
they're still
dying so the lack of information is
actually if you're a knowing person and
many of the people in these Health
departments in states are knowing
knowing people if they know and they're
not stepping forward then it's
murder uh if you turn the page over Gary
Dayton um died April 30 2022 he was 82
years old this requires
investigation he actually died in
Connecticut that's why it says
Connecticut on a death certificate but
he was a resident of Hanover New
Hampshire and a cerebrovascular accident
that's a
stroke New Hampshire resident Robert
Miles II 39 years old died 4 days after
immunization he had a heart transplant
in
2017 I knew that these drugs were
prothrombotic in February of
2021 by reading the Bears dat it was
obvious and and my analyses even there's
a video of me in APR from April of
20121 and in that video I have listed
many of the deaths from pulmonary UL
ISM and
other excuse me and other prothrombotic
type of um
causes so that's a 39y
old oh and then Anna Tucker was
26 she was immunized one day before she
died on January 8th she was immunized on
January 7th passed away peacefully in
her sleep
stou
grf two days earlier December
22nd he was vaccinated earlier than the
death date which is Christmas Eve 2021
unexpectedly and if we look at the
graphs these are I don't have access to
the New Hampshire data which is which is
a problem because nobody in New
Hampshire has access to it either that's
what I was trying to do with hb1 1661
was get the people of New Hampshire to
get the data and that doesn't mean
divulging people's names this means
knowing what's happening in New
Hampshire what are people dying from so
these um if you understand the term
ketris paribus it means all other things
being equal or in
parity
and Through the Years people you from
New Hampshire utilize Massachusetts
hospitals and they travel to
Massachusetts and so forth and so all
the other things being equal say the
number of people use the hospitals and
so forth um let's look at that in look
at these graphs in that light and you'll
notice in the top left are the
D68 codes these These are icd10 codes
these are the codes used internationally
put out by the wh a subset of which is
adopted by the
CDC and so New Hampshire what you will
do is is you will create a death record
with part one and part two part one is
the causes of death and it'll be ABC D
in backward time order the way it should
be but the doctors don't know how to do
it right so they get it backwards a lot
of times and part two is contributing
conditions usually like you know asthma
smoking alcoholic um conditions that may
have contributed to the cause of
death so all other things being equal in
these clot deaths you'll notice that in
2015 it was four and then 2016 it was
four and then three and then two then
five and then six and then in 2021 when
the shots came out it was
12 it's more than double the average
more than double the
trend no matter how you look at it it's
more than double in a single year and if
you look at anemas so there's there's
thomy toena and then there's just
regular anemia um
neutropenia there a lot of a lot of
anemas I I call it anemas that means
you're you're you're lacking some type
of
uh of of blood cell of which you think
of three types the thrombocytes are your
platelets right so they're for clotting
and stuff and then your white cells for
killing off bad stuff in your body and
red cells for basically carrying oxygen
mostly um
take a look at the graph you know it's
it's pretty substantial and Stark when
you look at
21 what is happening to New Hampshire
people
dying a lot more in
21 from a cause that wasn't really high
in 20120 2020 was the year of covid huge
first wave in
Massachusetts I think the only reason
that huge first wave didn't happen in
New Hampshire is because you don't have
the financial incentive that we have in
Massachusetts and the world should know
about Massachusetts I I'll I'll I'm
going to take a break and tell you about
Massachusetts here for a second 600
Pharma ecosystem companies in
Massachusetts alone $47 billion in
Venture Capital financing there are 50
companies over $100 million a year in
Pharma and revenue in Massachusetts 10
companies over a billion dollars mad's
headquarters and R&D is in Massachusetts
fizer's divisional headquarters for the
MRNA vaccine is in Massachusetts relle
walinsky is from Massachusetts my
congressman is Jake oen Claus's as Huen
class worked for fouchy for 20 years as
his number
two that's all
Massachusetts and if you look at on J
July 27 2020 of all sovereigns in the
world with three million people or
more the top three purported covid
deaths per population were New York New
Jersey and Massachusetts with Belgium a
distant fourth so far distant that
Massachusetts was 50% more than Belgium
and I'll offend Belgium here by saying
they're probably one of the most corrupt
countries over there in
Europe so if if they're that way what is
ma what are Massachusetts New York and
New Jersey and why why New York and New
Jersey well you've got Wall Street New
Jersey's based Northern New Jersey is
just a suburb of Wall Street Lower
Manhattan so all the executives live out
in the BBS in uh in New
Jersey they padded the numbers quite a
bit how do you prove it good luck I can
prove it in Massachusetts because I have
the records but New York Won't Give Up
the ghost they won't give up the records
so when I talk about Massachusetts it's
not just that I live there it's not just
that I have the data there because I'm
also going to review some Minnesota data
it's that Massachusetts New York and New
Jersey fooled the world and I'll show
you the fraud that they committed acute
fenal intoxication they tested dead
bodies oh positive covid test it's a
covid death blunt force trauma to the
Head blunt force trauma to the Torso old
ladies fallen down the stairs in the
Care Homes because nobody was there to
care for them because oh
co they called these deaths covid deaths
they padded numbers if they're willing
to go so far and commit such fraud for
accidental deaths what do you think they
did for heart attacks for 95 year
olds in the CDC memorandum I'll save
myself some time flipping to the page I
also have Vermont
records a 98-year-old old she died from
a heart attack who's going to say
anything about
that but I matched her up with A's
record of the only 98-year-old who died
on the same
day and she was injected two days before
and what happened her heart rate went to
145 beats per minute at 98 years old she
was dead in two days it wasn't mentioned
on her on her death record but I found
the data they killed her with the jab
and then they hit it and refused to
mention it this absolute evidence that
the vaccine killed this woman woman now
yeah who's going to mourn oh 98 years
old that's sad right she was a person
she didn't deserve to go by having her
heart race for two days from and we know
that Tac cardia and disautonomia and
I'll show you some graphs about
disautonomia has occurred from these
Jabs so clots in the
brain I mean the graph says it all you
know 11 8 10 10 177 13 13 and then
27 again it doubles you twice the number
of deaths and if you Jeffrey was from
Hudson New Hampshire he had a stroke in
days
hypercoagulable so hyper
claing oh cerebral beus sinus thrombosis
cvst interventricular Hemorrhage he was
hemorrhaging all over his
body in
days uh Elaine was 61 she died she was
from Rochester New Hampshire 61 years
old died January 5th 2022 cerebral
herniation in hours multifocal cerebral
infarcts aortic dissection in days
aortic dissection and a cerebral
herniation the heart is not that close
to the brain why is she having a hole
eaten through her the endothelial lining
of her aorta at the same time having a
massive
stroke have one or two which you know it
needs to be investigated because as I
sit here I think about my mom my mom had
a stroke uh and had had an abdominal
aortic aneurysm but that was a year
apart
um this woman who died having multiple
things going on needs to be investigated
clots in lungs so these are pulmonary
embolism it's very difficult to find in
the data
the uh neurological stroke and and other
issues for intracranial intraspinal
issues because the codes by the CDC the
G Codes are scattered across about 50
codes but PR pulmonary embolism deaths
there's only two as big as your lungs
are there's only two as big as your
brain is there 50 to give you an idea of
how to trace data in in this regard um
so the clots in the lungs right so
that's ponary
rism take a look at
2021 you get 9 12 11 14 16 16
27 Lindsay was 27 years old from Newton
New Hampshire died August 4th
2021 pulmonary thrombo
emo and a DBT deep Bain
thrombos they probably go together
because you get a clot in your leg and
your calf right and they call it
throwing a CL
goes up to your lung and then you could
have ventricular failure and die Jeffrey
was 30 I just listen to these
ages 30 years
old died November 7 2021 in eping New
Hampshire or he's from eping New
Hampshire cardiogenic shock massive
pulmonary
embolism and I I told you about
um a million people have been killed by
uh drug and Hospital protocols so it's
not just about the
vaccine I'll be speaking in Houston
Texas at halt Hospital homicides too
it's the second one they're going to
have in um on June
1st it if you could just sit on some of
these
calls with people who've lost their
husbands their wives their
children and to hear what the hospitals
did to these people all around the
country and I imagine imine that New
Hampshire is probably no different red
state blue State this is not politics at
all this is centralization of
authority that creates marginal losses
as they push out you know you have a
central point of failure when they push
out what they want you to take the
doctors just do it they don't want to
lose their
license and and I've you've got the
evidence on that so 150,000 excess
sudden kidney failure deaths alone this
is
excess so this is more than normal and
when you flip this over so I'll say
there a million Americans have been
killed by both the vaccines and the
hospital protocols I don't know which
one is more I I tend to think the
hospital protocols killed more
people so let's look at New
Hampshire um
oops there it is all right let's take a
look at New Hampshire residents who died
in Massachusetts top left where it says
cut sudden kidney
failure do you see a problem
here 2021 2022 2023 is not here imagine
where that is maybe it drops you know I
don't know Joseph died he was uh 30
years old from Franklin New
Hampshire died on December 28 2022
multi-stem organ
failure pneumonia flu stapac cacus orius
sudden kidney failure
it it's not that you know everybody says
remes takes out your kidneys it's remes
it's remes I don't know I'm not a doctor
I'm not a
biologist I have six medical files of
deant that families have given me one is
12,000 Pages the other's 6,000 one's
4,000 the hospitals are so nice that
when they give these to the families
they're not searchable they give them
images so I had to run it through a
software program and Optical character
recognition to build the words from the
images and when that took an hour to run
then I could search for REM Desir
baricitinib and vamy so I I don't know
some people say it's barit nib some
people say it's from dvir I personally
think it's vamy in combination with one
of the other two I believe van vom is a
very very strong um antibiotic but
here's the protocol it's given and the
evidence in the CDC memorandum with
individual cases I I'll read probably
one of them so we won't take too much
time and you'll see and here here's the
protocol or a there are variations of
it I'll just talk about Danielle now
I'll do it from memory but it it's in
the CDC
memorandum 28-year old
woman her mother got nervous that she
tested positive for Co at home home and
she had a neighbor uh used the little
finger pulseox and the neighbor said oh
it's it's only 87 you should bring her
in right away so she brought her in she
was 95% oxygen when she got there 95%
not a problem
right because she had a positive covid
test they started her on remes and
started running that stuff through her
veins immediately 200 milligrams first
day then you go 100 100 100 100 it's a
5day course so you go 200 and then 100
for four days
that wasn't enough money though to get a
CO diagnosis and R doe they had to get
get around the
ventilator so I I looked at the time uh
and again you know I'm telling you these
are thousands of pages and as I go
through time there were hourly um vital
signs that were taken on her and then
there was probably I don't know if it
was daily blood check um but there were
it was often they were checking her
blood so her liver enzymes were actually
fine um even through the rim does appear
but her Vital
Signs it was in the area of um 60 beats
per minute heart rate um her breathing
was about 15 breaths per minute this
this is all normal right
97.8 or nine uh was her temperature did
not have a temperature she didn't have a
breathing problem she didn't have a
pulseox problem she didn't have a
temperature problem she didn't have a
heart rate
problem when they put her on a
ventilator at 95 5%
oxygen and they killed her she didn't
need it but they got their extra money
because if you incentivize something
you'll get more of it and they got this
28-year-old why she was learning
disabled she couldn't she couldn't
defend herself and her mother was not
allowed to see her at that
point and so she developed the lung
infection which happens when you get put
on um May I just interject to ask a
question absolutely representative thank
you very much uh and thank you for for
all of this um so when it comes to and
I've heard you talk about the
ventilators a few times now and I think
that's a very important thing for us to
look at I've heard and I don't recall
exactly where where I've heard it um so
I'm wondering if you have any
information regarding this that the uh
protocols for early extremely aggressive
ventilator use um may have originated
with the World Health Organization and
been pushed down from there is that
something that you've heard have any
awareness of or have any evidence for I
I don't want to answer something I don't
know fair enough but I know if you go to
the NIH and that's where I believe you
should start your investigation uh not
the CDC necessarily but the NIH and how
to treat this I think that's where it
originated if if not the
who all right thank you um so yeah she
uh she got put on um the ventilator
developed the lung infection they
couldn't stop it she went septic they
tried bomy of course and her kidneys
failed and the gentleman from New
Hampshire I just mentioned with the
multi-organ failure I mean everything
goes wrong in the body they're they're
pumping them so full of the drugs and
here are the drugs they they kind of get
you ready for going on a ventilator mzm
lorazapam fentanyl propal
dexamine all of them I'm not saying one
or the other they're hitting you with
the anti-anxiety they're hitting you
with the uh the painkiller they're
hitting you with
everything and they they
basically kill people
I don't mean to interrupt um and I know
you're not a medical
doctor but I'm just trying to wrap my
head around the
fact that if when you're speaking
about the one person where they come in
and their oxygen rate really isn't that
low they don't have a fever they don't
have
anything and then they put them you're
saying the protocol is to put them on
like five or
more drugs for lack of a better
word that that is the protocol for
basically anyone that they're prepping
for a
ventilator yeah and and yeah you can't
put somebody on a ventilator unless you
get them all calm and you know
get you're gonna you're going to have to
ask a doctor about this because the
doctors have a lot to answer for they're
doing what they're told but I did what I
was told is not a defense for
murder I appreciate that representative
Bel did you have something thank you yes
I just wanted to provide a little bit of
information because I have a healthcare
background I was a paramedic for quite
some time um when it comes to
historically ventilating patients um I
will say it's not necessarily uncommon
to ventilate before hypoxia sets in
because once hypoxia sets in uh through
low blood oxygen um it can uh quickly go
very quickly go south from there so
typically what people look at or what
they historically would look at is uh
work of breathing indicators suggesting
muscle fatigue that suggests breathing
is failing um in order to uh to
ventilate um I think the big thing we
want to look at here given some of this
testimony we've heard is we want to
verify whether there was a deviation
from looking at these tradition
metrics such as work of breathing in
especially in order to do anything akin
to um to control of the uh of the of the
spread of the pathogen because that
would be a very interesting finding if
these people are truly overriding
traditional metrics for ventilation in
order to provide some sort of a
containment thank you for that please
what he said I agree with everything it
needs to be investigated and that's the
point is not whether REM Desir vanam
Baris sanib and other Protocols are
killing people's kidneys the point is
the criminal omission of conduct to
investigate by the CDC by the FDA by the
NIH all three directors of those
organizations and 13 of their Deputy
directors received a copy of this
certified mail they were served not this
bound one but a loose one with um this
one has about five or six names changed
in Minnesota because they didn't want
their names in it so I said okay p and
their names are not in but all the other
names in here are correct so they
received this and once they've been
notified they can't unknow they have a
legal duty to act okay you you and I
don't have that Duty well you sort of
have that Duty you you're you're members
of the general court you're officers of
the court of New Hampshire so you do
have the legal duty to investigate this
is and that that is what you're doing
but at the CDC they refuse to
investigate what's killed 150,000 excess
people by a single cause of death that's
the worst thing since
1918 and it doesn't matter what you
believe about the Spanish Flu whether it
was the virus or secondary bacterial
infection that killed
people you just got to know that there
were a lot of extra people who died and
it Bears investigating and we have the
ability to investigate all the
information is in CDC and and state
databases they refuse to investigate if
I had access to the information within a
week I can tell you and I'm not even a
doctor because I'll just go through and
find the common thread of all the people
that died from acute Rena failure how
many got remir how many got bankam how
many got both how many got aluman baras
ciip so the omission of conduct of
Investigation is the
crime they're they're killing people and
and they don't want to know in fact
they'll kill your kids and go out for
sushi that day and laugh about it sorry
I had to throw that
in all right so you'll notice that the
pattern of New Hampshire deaths from
Sudden kidney failure in the top left
which is a 100%
increase and that's 2728 people in 2022
alone and that's just New Hampshire
residents in Massachusetts hospitals or
in MA or in the state of
Massachusetts imagine how many hundreds
in New
Hampshire hundreds of excess acute renal
failure deaths in New
Hampshire they're killing your citizens
now look at
Massachusetts you'll see 2,000 excess
2,000 EXs people in Massachusetts alone
in the top right in the bottom
left 1600 excess
Minnesota 1,600 EXs Minnesota this does
not include 2023 if I include 2023 I'll
say more than 3,000 excess renal failure
deaths in Massachusetts alone so when I
say 150,000 across the United States I
mean
it and in the bottom right I'm not at
Liberty to say yet but does the graph
look familiar to you it's the same as
all the others this is an insane amount
of excess deaths by acute reenal failure
these are not happening at home these
are happening in hospitals I I
there's work in progress that I can't
really talk about and um within a couple
months you guys keep doing your work to
investigate and you'll have a lot more
information to rely upon in a couple
months from multiple entities
coordinated okay I went through uh these
so I testified for Bill hb1
1661 and after I testified for that bill
and I answered all questions um there
there there was only one question that
kind of threw me it was the second time
that same person
asked uh Bill H hb1 1661 real quickly it
it's more than just trying to get the
vaccines put on death certificates for
anybody who died within two years of a
vaccine that's part one right there's
four sections the second section compels
quarterly reports from the state of New
Hampshire to the people saying how many
people died within one day three days
one week three weeks 10 weeks 25 weeks
and one year of vaccin of of any type of
immunization but the the the third and
fourth are the most important the third
compels the state to do an investigation
much like I've done and I'm one
man I'm just one guy with and and if
you've you've seen my work some of it
this only a piece of it then you'll know
that it's the most
comprehensive uh Public Health
analysis ever
anywhere I can tell you every cause of
death um I can't tell you definitively
what happened because many of the causes
of death rely upon the custom and
practice of the local medical examiner's
office so you'll find different patterns
in Minnesota than you will in
Massachusetts because they were taught
how to fill out death certificats
differently write different words and
when those words go to the CDC they get
run through transacts and acne software
and the words are that I I started to
tell you before part one and part two
right so New Hampshire fills out the
words they go to the CDC again a single
point of failure they get run through
the
software and that applies codes and that
is the only way we as Citizens know
what's happening is to track the codes
because you can't read all the different
words that all the crazy doctors write
on death certificates the medical
examiners are pretty consistent because
they do about 400 per year of uh death
records um but a regular doctor you know
it depends if there's a doctor in a care
home he might do you know 20 or 30 a
year um but a regular doctor a family
practitioner probably only does one or
two every couple years right how many
people die in the office of a of a
doctor so when they do one they don't do
a good job but um the software is
supposed to pick out the words and then
apply the codes
if they're using different words and
I'll give you an example in Minnesota
then Massachusetts then New Hampshire
right so here's Minnesota c41 bone and
articular cartilage cancer is way up in
Massachusetts bone and bone marrow
cancer is way up well that's c41 and
that's
c79 they're completely different but if
if they if it manifests the same in the
human body and it's the same
disease for bone maybe bone marrow but
they just write a different word saroma
or whatever it gets picked up
differently by the transacts and Acme
software and coded differently so now we
think we're getting good information so
the Integrity of the data relies upon
custom and practice of human behavior in
every office and therefore you should
not look at the entire United States you
should look regionally to see what has
happened uh because of like I explained
earlier ketris
parabo all
right I I want to read the uh response I
sent to the house members after my
testimony and after the um HHS DHHS
people
testified um please stop and ask
questions
anytime um all right I'll try to go
through this
quickly so after testif testifying I
fielded questions from house members um
I I didn't know somebody told me the
parties were on different sides I I
don't know how you guys sit I didn't
know who I was talking to but I can say
that it seemed very fair there were
questions from both sides and um I found
out later that you know I I had
challenging questions from from both
sides you know and I answered all of
them um but I I found it to be a good
experience for hb1 1661 not the prior
testimony at the Senate hearing that was
not a good experience where people just
wouldn't even pay attention to 11 and
seven and and 12 year olds dying from
the VAC seen and they just typing away
and talking to each other but let me
um so again it seems to have gone well
let me uh read some of the letter that I
had sent um email I should say that I
had sent to some of the house members
after so thank you for hosting me for a
short description of hb1 1661 with great
regret I'm compelled to provide you
information regarding the DHHS Bureau
Chief's testimony that followed mine I
will wait a few days before I publish
this commentary know
my hearing is not good and I couldn't
hear the names of the bureau Chiefs one
was a man one was a woman I'll have to
go with these as identifiers here and a
House member asked the Bureau of chiefs
if DH now this this is all in video so
you could say oh it's hearsay but you
can go listen to the video it's there a
House member asked uh the bureau Chiefs
if DHHS is alarmed about sudden deaths
in New Hampshire the gentleman bureau
chief
answer was mere and only included
looking at death records database the
gentleman also mentioned that if there
was a covid vaccine caused injury it
would be reported through the US hhs's
vaccine adverse event reporting
system that answer should frighten all
of you if somebody dies go go talk to
Bears you know we're not going to
investigate in New Hampshire that's
that's not what the public health in New
Hampshire does really that that's pretty
frightening so when asked further by a
House member if DHHS was alarmed at the
amount and ages of sudden deaths
including a 27-year-old and teenagers
and if DHHS was doing anything like
forming a committee to look at what is
happening the woman bureau chief
answered she stated that her office
focuses on certain indicators and that
she had her staff look into the most
current death record data to see if
there are any vaccine caused adverse
effects listing icd10 code u129
and I explained icd10 codes before right
so what is uh e129 I'll tell you in a
minute
but the codes are managed by the
wh a subset of them is used by the CDC
remember
that so not not all icd10 codes are
adopted by the CDC it seems that the
individual US states only apply codes
approved for use by the CDC in fact most
if not all states send death records to
the CDC without the cd10 codes the CDC
then runs the pros the words of the
death
certificates Parts one and two through
the transaction AC me software these
software programs apply the codes the
death records are then returned with
codes to the respective
States if all that the wom bureau chief
has ever done to monitor potential
vaccine death is to look for
u129 then she will not find any and in
the hearing she stated that she did not
find any
neither is u129 F9 found in nearly 1
million and I can now say 1.4 million
death records that I have from Minnesota
Massachusetts and another
state why the CDC seems not to have
adopted this code from The Who a search
of cdc's website shows no mention of
u129 however a full web search shows
that Germany and the United Kingdom have
adopted it in the context which follows
there's a stunning notation on the who's
document which has no official markings
on it but can be found on their
website the notation for u12 prefix is
as follows
u129 now here's what it means covid-19
vaccines causing adverse effects and
therapeutic use unspecified note this
code is to be used as an external cause
code it s as a subcategory under
y59 remember that it's to be used under
y59 other and unspecified vaccines by
iCal
substances in addition to this a code
from another chapter of the
classification could be used indicating
the nature of the adverse effect correct
administration of covid-19 vaccine and
prophylactic therapeutic use as the
cause of any adverse effect okay on the
website of the office of national
statistics of the United Kingdom is a
very similar notation I won't read it to
you it's it's the same wording as who
they're saying that yeah there's u129
but it's a subcategory of y59 and we're
not really using one 12.9 and now you
know that the CDC has no record of even
using it and you're DHHS the one who's
head of all the data that's the only
thing she looked for and it's not even
in use in the United States and then
they're not looking at vaccine deaths in
any other
way that is Extreme call it dereliction
of Duty but it's omission of conduct
where they have a legal duty to act and
to investigate the deaths
now comes the difficult part to tell you
it's to be used as a subcategory under
y59 not not only is there no mention of
u129 on the CDC website and no use of it
on nearly well I'll say 1.4 million
death certificates but even the UK and
who state that it's a subcategory
y59 y59 was used on both Massachusetts
and Minnesota and now I can tell you the
third state I've found it in there in
the database
y59 is used in three other states two of
them very local to
you y 59.0 means viral
vaccines it appears the New Hampshire
Bureau Chiefs health and statistics and
informatics bureau chief for health
statistics and informatics has not
looked for the right information in the
death record database this is basic
information I've known for years now she
should have searched for Wi-Fi
but that's not the only one there are
plenty of other codes that transacts and
acne software may put out for vaccine
cause death
t881 also used in Massachusetts and
Minnesota death records means other
complications following immunization not
elsewhere
classified in Minnesota was also found a
t509 which means other and unspecified
drugs medicaments and biological
substances so depending on how it's
written vaccine or vaccination on the
death certificate
you'll find that it gets coded
differently can I just check time how
much I'm good okay the house members
should also know that specific and
credible evidence shows that the CDC
committed several acts of felony fraud
against the People by hiding vaccine
caused
deaths I'm going to
uh I'm just going to skip right to the
the memorandum now so just open it up
and there are paragraph numbers
inside and go to let's say page
58 oh
sorry
yeah okay um on page
58 before paragraph 49 CDC response to
journalist
inquiry on July 3rd that's my birthday
all right I shouldn't have said that out
public everybody knows my birthday now
almost the 4th of July baby so on July
3rd 2023 Aaron harzburg published an
article in Brownstone Institute entitled
CDC altered Minnesota death certificates
that list the covid vaccine as a cause
of
death the article can be found well I
have I have all the links are in here
everything's published herzberg's thesis
in the article is an accusation by
Herzberg of fraud committed by the CDC
in the omission of icd10 codes Y 59.0
and t881 from Minnesota death
certificates that expressly mention
vaccine or
vaccination in part one or part two
Herzberg wrote now here's a quote from
the
article in almost every death
certificate that that identifies a covid
vaccine as a cause of death the CDC
committed data fraud by not assigning
the icd10 code for vaccine side effects
to the causes of death listed on the
death
certificate paragraph 50 on July 5th
2023 at 9:12 PM Greg Piper of just the
news sent an email to Media CDC
basically cdc's public
relations the subject was media requests
covid vaccine death icd10 codes withheld
question mark the body of the email
States hello this is Greg Piper at just
the news in DC I wanted to get the
agency's response to this reported
discovery about your categorization of
Minnesota death
certificates on July 6 2023 10:46 a.m.
Kristen nordland of CDC public affairs
replied to Greg Piper of just the
news the response email from nordland is
an unintelligible word salad seemingly
debating the difference between the word
vaccine and the word vaccination the
email appears to be an attempt to
misinform disinform and outright
prevaricate expressing that there is no
unusual pattern of illness or death
resulting from Co
immunizations here is the email from
Kristen nordland to Greg Piper hi Greg
thanks for reaching out to CDC the claim
in the post is incorrect the icd10 codes
in question pertain to adverse effects
of vaccines not vaccination vaccination
is not a disease or cause of death so
simple mention of the vaccine or
vaccination without mention of ad
effects will not get coded does that
make sense to anybody
here does it when when I said it's an
unintelligible word salad was I
exaggerating I mean that's rhetorical
you don't have to answer um the examples
in this now here I go on this is what
she wrote the examples in this article
for which adverse effects codes are
included are those that mention adverse
or side effects of vaccine the examples
for which the codes are not included do
not contain such language
covid-19 vaccines are undergoing the
most intense safety monitoring in US
history so intense that they don't look
at death certificates that actually say
vaccine as a cause of death to date CDC
has not detected any unusual or
unexpected patterns for deaths following
immunization that would indicate that
covid vaccines are causing or
contributing to Deaths outside of the
nine confirmed ttf TTS deaths following
the Jansen vaccine if you're not
familiar with the term limited
hangout you should probably look that up
there's a very quick definition of it
very easy where they admit to a small
piece so people will go away and not
investigate further for the whole
truth and she goes on when an adverse
Event Event including death is reported
to cdc's vaccine adverse event reporting
system is classified as serious or
non-serious the code of Federal
Regulation defined serious as death
life-threatening illness hospitalization
or prolonged hospitalization permanent
disability congenital anomalies or birth
defects for
reports classified as serious CDC
requests and reviews The Available
medical records examines death
certificates and autopsy reports the
determination of cause of death
is done by certifying by the certifying
official who completes the death
certificate or pathologist who conducts
the autopsy thanks Kristen
if you go to paragraph
one on
page you could probably find it faster
than me let's
see paragraph one is on page
22 I will skim through this so we're
gonna have to go faster um on January 16
2021 Solomon kizo died he was 60 years
old acute Bronco pneumonia and
idiopathic thrombocytopenia following
covid-19
vaccination vaccination not vaccine it
does not say side effect of it does not
say adverse effect of if you look at the
codes the CDC assigned transacts acne
code to be Y 59.0 which means viral
vaccines in other words and this is
Massachusetts Kristen nordin's excuse to
Greg Piper was tailored to the three
Minnesota death certificates that have y
59.0 one says side effect of the other
says adverse effect of and they do not
say vaccination they say
vaccine by tailoring her excuse to the
three
records that have it written and the
other records that say vaccine
vaccination weren't coded so in in
Minnesota three were coded and the other
six that followed were not in
Massachusetts Solomon kizo right here
this official government record proves
that she lied to Greg Piper and
committed further felony fraud in
writing expressly written in her
email it also shows that the CDC is not
going to change their ways and is not
going to protect the public nor are they
going to investigate the further eight
other Massachusetts records that say
vaccine and vaccination all documented
in the CDC memorandum right here Solomon
kizo after January 16 the WiFi 9
disappears it's not used again in
Massachusetts and after the three in
Minnesota for the next six it is not
used this is an automatic software
program that applies codes yes they do
manual intervention sometimes but the if
they manually intervene to add y59 why
didn't they do it for the others why did
they stop doing it to hide vaccine
caused deaths from the American
people and I can tell you that in the
third state I found the same thing y59
is
coded the next three or not one was
coded the next three or not they did the
same thing logic will tell you that
either they're deleting y59 after
transacts and act me codes for it or
they're Manu they manually stopped
coding for it either of which is an
intentional action against the people to
hide vaccine cause deaths from the
people even the medical examiners and
doctors wrote vaccine and vaccination on
the death certificate they wanted us to
know and I can go to let let's take a
look at who happened first Brianna um we
can go to
Brianna's death record
um
page well let me let me do Diane's
first page 25 paragraph 5 on March 18
2021 Diane V died she was 62 years
old here's part one of her dust
certificate acute intracranial
hemorrhage in the setting of
thrombocytopenia in a person treated
with covid-19 vaccination 11 days prior
to
presentation it's on her death
certificate this the the person who
wrote this death certificate wants you
to know she died from the vaccine there
are no codes here y 590 and t881 are
absent this is an omission of material
fact and therefore a false writing on
official documents as a matter of custom
and
practice
both the uh the CDC is guilty they have
been notified they've been given this
document they've been given other
documents they were contacted by Greg
Piper and they are looking at you and
saying we don't care about New Hampshire
we're going to keep doing what we're
doing page um
26 paragraph
7 this is on the uh New Hampshire border
very
close um close to Salem so Bri Brianna
lived in hail but she grew up in methu
she was a high school teacher she died
on March 30 excuse me on March 30th
2021 she was injected with a single dose
of
madna the v's report was entered by a
practicing
nurse uh a severe headache appears to
have been appears to have begun only
hours following immunization ensued for
days until Brianna was admitted to
hospital then degraded into a seizure
brain lesions paralysis and brain
activity
stopped so she reacted in hours to the
vaccine she was removed from life
support about two and a half weeks later
Brianna died officially on April 15 2021
at years old her death record
States non-traumatic cerebral
herniation in other words she wasn't hit
in the
head es schic stroke clots in her
head and um no
mention no no y59 on her death record
it's not there now did they really know
well let's find out
um I'm going to do this from memory
because it's easier and I I've presented
this a million times so there were six
doctors from Harvard Medical College
Beth Israel deaconness Hospital where
she died and they wrote a brief report
in the neurohospitalist journal and and
the report is titled fatal postco mRNA
vaccine Associated cerebral esia and
that means the vaccine killed her by
stroke they wrote a report about it in
every paragraph of that report it says
the vaccine killed her by
stroke it says where thros cytopenia Is
frequent remember Diane Dua two weeks
before Brianna got injected she died if
they had investigated her death and they
knew they wrote it on the death
certificate what killed her but they
covered it up and because they covered
it up banna's
dead
so you you have a society where we sit
here and wonder how can this happen it
can't be it can't be all lies this many
people can't be
involved but the facts stay
otherwise they wrote the report they
said where thrombocytopenia Is frequent
they also said where cvst is they have a
number of reports on C cvst is cerebral
Venus sinus thrombosis it's a kind of
hemorrhagic stroke I said but Briana
didn't have that but they're common
where hypen Is frequent they also say
they have a number of reports of Strokes
from Co vaccinations plural in other
words not just the Mna not just the
Jansen not just the
fiser it's all of
them and I'm gonna I'm going to skip I
mean you see how extensive all these
facts are these are facts can't get away
from
it um
page 28 paragraph
11 on May 23rd 2021 the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts a 17-year-old girl was
injected with a second dose of covid
immunization the onset date States June
7 the v's report continues
um well I I I'm going to read just part
of it
so she got her shot and then she had a
headache so bad she went to her primary
care physician twice and when her
headache resolved in a week or two she
got her second
shot and the quote is it then resolved
and she got her second
vaccine massive acute int cranial
Hemorrhage large interventricular
Hemorrhage massive brain swelling in
infarctions on her death certificate she
died
from complications of cerebral Venus
sinus thrombosis this was 5 weeks after
Briana the doctors
knew they knew the vaccine caused
stroke and so the only thing coded was a
g08 which means intracranial intraspinal
fitis and Throop
fitis so I just told you about three
Strokes in three women in three months
in early
2021 all attributed to the vaccine
without a
doubt and yet they hid them they covered
them up they didn't tell the public
about them and Amaya was 12 years old I
I'll just I'll I'll speak from memory
it's in
here 12 years old they gave her four
shots they gave her HPV minin cockle
Tdap and they gave her her third Co shot
on August 3rd
2022 I don't know how long the hospital
stayed
were I'm sure she had the headaches
pretty soon after but she was officially
dead on August 29th same
month now you could say well Eden and
Amaya had um congenital defects in the
vasculature of their brains okay did
they deserve to be taken out 10 years
earlier than they otherwise would have
by this shot because we know the shots
are killing people by stroke we know
that they're killing people by clots
and then the reason I got all this
information is on page
31 paragraph
15 I heard on the radio that a
seven-year-old girl died from covid and
I knew that was that was a lie so I
looked into it and I got all these death
certificates and um so I'll just I'll
just read the paragraph and then I can
move on to some graphs on on January 13
2022 in the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts a 7-year-old girl was
injected with covid immunization
according to bears ID 20 38120 entered
into vs on January 15 that's important
so it was entered on the
15th and she was injected on the 13th
now this is a a V's record so there's no
name and the vs record States severe
nausea and vomiting from 5 minutes post
vaccination and for the next 8 to 10
hours and then the next field States
spiked a 103 degree fever severe stomach
ache now so this is the second
vaccination that that other one was for
the first vaccination prior
back so here's here's the one about this
vaccination spiked a 103 degree fever
severe stomach ache had not had a bowel
movement since the day before
vaccination which makes today three days
without
one her bowel is shut
down I I assume there's no blood supply
there bow lemia there's also been many
hemorrhages if you read through here and
and I could show you many death
certificates where people just started
hemorrhaging from their
bowels or they had esia they their Bowes
shut down because they you can't get a
blood supply to it how can the muscles
contract to push food
along first vaccine caused severe Nom I
don't know have to read that again
um so I go on to list the number of uh
V's reports and death certificates they
in proxim
of um this girl Cassidy Baraka it's only
only Cassidy baraka's death certificate
fits if you don't mind me asking I'm
just curious uh to find out how you got
involved in obtaining the data and why
you chose to dig
in yeah
so I I raised three boys pretty much on
my own for a while and then I lost my
son in a motorcycle
accident so I was just sitting there on
a couch doing nothing for a couple of
years and um Co hit and it's basically
destroying my other two sons with all
the the rules and everything like that's
all Bs because as an engineer I know the
masks aren't going to work why are you
asking doctors the doctor can read the
Box they don't understand material
properties Material Science they've
never studied that they don't understand
fluid Dynamics unless maybe they're a
vascular surgeon and they might have had
to take a course in it and even then I
would challenge them to understand
branolia equations especially with
regard to the aortic Arch and stuff so
why did I get into it because I found
that people that specialize in in
purviews they they the solution is right
here but but they're like this and they
can't see it and just step back and
learn a little bit about something else
like
how many people are looking at all the
fiser trial data I don't care about it
do you think the criminal is going to
give you the evidence to hang them they
they're leaking out that as slowly as
they can that as slowly as the judge
allows and what are they leaking out
you're not going to find anything in
there there's a couple of things that
are like oh look what we found but they
have thousands and thousands of people
looking at the fizer
data why we have billions of people
who've been injected we have I mean I
have one 1.4 million death certificates
that are worth far more than any fiser
data that every state has access to the
immunization information system of the
state and all they have to do is
correlate the names from the IIs to
either the death records or the Medicaid
and Medicare because they also have
that and when I said I had whistleblower
data you can imagine what databases get
leaked out here and there but if anybody
finds out where it came from they'll
throw the person in
jail the data exists we could solve this
in one week in any
state that just does does a thorough
investigation oh excuse me a cursory
investigation in a week could put all
these vaccines to rest it is the Holy
Grail of information they will not let
out so why did I get into it because I
care about all the kids being killed
because their parents I don't want to
say so ignorant people think of as a bad
word it just means you don't know
something there's nothing wrong with the
word ignorant
the parents are ignorant because the
government has been lying to them and
hiding it and if you understand behavior
in systems and and I heard somebody
mention earlier um one one of you two
guys uh you know hhs.gov is is not
running this whole thing it's a joint
operation warp speed is a joint Mission
with
DOD whose DOD going to assign to do it
oh that's just for distribution they
don't have they don't have Army cargo
trucks driving around the country
delivering vaccines that's not their
mission their mission is a vaccine in
every arm that's what they were told
that's what they're going to do and when
the Smith month act part of it was
repealed under Obama that allowed them
to propagandize Americans so who got the
tap on the shoulder what division of
military military intelligence and what
did they do they infiltrated social
media that people like me have been
suppressed Terri
they attack people who've been back
injured people with transverse myus who
paralyzed from the waist down people who
lost their
kids cute kid helping out just walked in
the
room it's pretty funny should I wait or
continue continue
okay so you know I I don't
just understand like what I read but
also how people interact that was my job
for 30 years is to understand both the
formal and informal and these are all
things I've been taught the formal and
informal structure of an organization
because they're very
different but formerly what mission were
they given a needle in every arm what
tools do they know what tactics do they
take
they went out and they they violated the
Free Speech rights of all Americans not
all but the ones of us who were telling
the truth they called us
misinformation this is a fact we know
this if you look at so Aaron kot's got a
case um American First America First
legal has the foyer releases that is in
exhibit h of this they worked with
social media to suppress any voice that
was called
antivaccine how about we just wanted to
save people's lives from a gene drug
therapy never before deployed in humans
on
mass and it will never work because
those lipid nanoparticle uh delivery
mechanism that they use is it I I don't
want to get into all the specifics and
yes I can have a conversation with a
doctor and I probably know more than any
given doctor about the specifics of
these but I will never say I'm an
expert here here's an example before I
move on I was in a
group I've been I'm in a number of
groups but so a lot of phds a lot of
phds one guy was being attacked by his
university and they wanted to get rid of
him and all the other professors were
angry at him so the history professors
the philosophy professors the law
professors they are you get the vaccine
get the vaccine the three professors
that were being attacked the three
professors at this large University that
were being attacked were the three
Immunology professors they would not get
the vaccine they were being yelled at by
the history professors and the
philosophy and political science profess
does that make any sense to anybody so
did I hear you correctly it was the
immunologist professors that did not
want the vaccine they didn't get it they
weren't allowed on campus there's a
lawsuit I can't really I I I'm afraid to
use his name um it's public it's Byron
Bridal out of Canada University of GF in
Toronto I just wanted to make sure I
understood correctly that it was the
other professors ganging up on the
immunologist professors and they're the
ones that were refusing the vacine
correct thank you
yep so the the people should know that
you know there's there's evil and then
there's just I'm doing my job right and
some of these people from military
intelligence are just doing their job so
I personally I know I've been suppressed
on social media I mostly am on Twitter
now called
um I won't get into follower accounts
and what I saw the needle going
backwards you know um and and especially
when Robert F Kennedy Jr tweeted about
me and got 18,000 likes in six hours and
I got zero followers and I and I went
and I looked at it for half an hour and
it it was like
2997 3002 and then within a second 29.97
35 2997 310 29.97 anytime they were
added they were subtracted immediately
by what appears to be an algorithm can't
prove anything but I know that's what I
did I watched my phone um and you know I
have 30,000 now which is pretty modest
most people have hundreds of thousands
and for doing what I do um but I I I
believe that the CDC memorandum the the
prototypes for this were the ver Vermont
memorandum the Minnesota memorandum
served to the governors Public Health
Commissioners chief medical examiners
and and other people within the
States um I told you about the Vermont
woman there's another woman in here from
Vermont uh who died just just just a
horribly tragic mother uh she had lost
her mother and so she leaves the child
uh without anybody and um pulmonary
embolism and you know if you read these
things it says oh she was feeling
lethargic for a few days it's like yeah
she had a pulmonary embolism it doesn't
just kill you in a second sometimes you
know it it takes a while to form grow
and shut down the ventricle so
um yeah I all right let let me let me
get to what I wanted to get to
here if there's anything really
important we should get to that
okay that it's my
checklist did that did that course cares
act um yeah I'm I'm gonna I'll tell you
about Danielle Alvarez if I can find
it and and while you're looking I just
uh as a side note just so you understand
um we had a uh industrial hygienist in
here a few weeks back to discuss masks
and um how they work and uh who should
be giving guidance on them so it was
very
informative there there's a reason why
you did not hear from OSHA or NEOS those
the two organizations under hhs.gov
because if they had come
out they would have had to lied so you
have to find somebody who's going to lie
overtly Based on data and they couldn't
find anybody so they had people like
fouchi and people who know nothing about
medical devices how they're manufactured
material properties of them and the the
effectiveness and um yeah an industrial
hygienist knows that you have to be
trained you have to be fit tested every
single time uh they're they're all just
meant as a behavior control mechanism to
get people to vaccinate all right right
so
I'm oh I should just go to the beginning
and look at the page
number that's why I made a table of
contents okay
97 page 97
if you go to the covid humanity material
memory Project chbm online you will see
hundreds of people who tell their
stories true stories of being murdered
in
hospitals um they're they're horrific
stories I've been on several calls with
these people crying into the
phone
um people being handcuff the beds not
being able to see them being put on
drugs they said they do not want to be
on on expressly they get put on him
anyway so the hospital gets the money
because that drug has to be given for
the hospital to get the money REM do
here all right so at the bottom of page
97 Danielle in October 2023 um her mom
gave me a bunch of
Records
um Danielle Kathleen Alvarez was
admitted on August 27
2021 I have the names of uh the doctors
uh so Heather Melman jincy Jacob was a
nurse they started her on um so she was
a they entered the
order at um 3:04 p.m. to give her remes
of here so as soon as they get a
positive covid test bam they hit her
with that R Dee so her Vital Signs 97.9
temperature 82 beat per minute heart
rate 119 over 87 blood pressure 15
breasts per minute
sound like she was struggling she wasn't
struggling there's no
struggle
um all right then they started hitting
her with the courses of R doir I have a
lot of details in here I'm just going to
kind of skip but I mean 97.3 81 beats
per minute she's nervous she's learning
disabled she's alone her mom isn't
allowed to be with her pulse sock was
down to
94% and then on page 99
um just more more data I'm giving you
leading up to the uh
ventilation I guess at this point I just
this is a a lot of pages I'll just say
the facts are
here and and these can be used to
convict these people and murder they
murdered this
girl um now I guess I'll finish up with
some graphs if you go to look what I
just I I just want to make sure um you
know we keep men the r Desir yeah but
you mentioned early that you don't know
if it was R Desir you're not saying it's
Desir is that correct that is correct
thank you and there a lot of people are
going to be very mad at me for not
saying it's R
Desir I'm not a cheerleader for anything
I go by facts and and data and evidence
and so I don't have the evidence that
it's from Desir what I have the evidence
of is that the government is not
investigating one of the largest mass
casualties in the history of the United
States they just don't care acute renal
failure they just don't care I told you
150,000 so well a million were killed by
Co no they weren't that's a
lie I also have in here I told you all
the fraud that occurred Massachusetts
New York New Jersey drove the fear of
this
pandemic because they had the most to
gain it was all a game it was all gamed
out from the very beginning the cares
Act was written in 2018
couple variables were tweaked in
2020 and they passed it they just pass
it whatever the lobbyist hands them here
pass this it's behavior modification to
get the doctors to do what they
want all right go to page 258
please I'm not I'm not going to do too
many because there there are 400 graphs
in
this by the way you you can buy this on
my website
you can buy it at Amazon too um that's
the the change names version the other
version that went to the CDC FDA and IH
had real real names and that's only uh
about like I said about four or five
people names are changed so on page
258 if you've heard of Turbo cancer this
is
it now the difference in 2020 on the top
left graph and 2020 is up
well you had 8,800 excess deaths in a
matter of nine weeks in 2020 from
mid-march to Mid June that's a lot of
old people the average death uh the
average age of of uh covid and the
average age of excess death was 81 in
Massachusetts and that that all happened
in nine weeks so you have a lot of
people that had lymph node cancer and
they were kind of cleared out by
whatever there was done to them mostly
neglect you know doctors will say you
died of covid but I I interviewed a a
medical examiner for three and a half
hours and reviewed hundreds of death
certificates with
him and he told
me we didn't do blood Labs we didn't do
imaging we didn't do tissue samples we
called up the old folks home said what
happened and they said well she was 95
was coughing and died it's like okay co
co co co co everything was Co they
didn't do their jobs because they were
afraid of the dead bodies but a doctor
would know dead bodies don't breathe
just use gloves which they use anyway
they weren't going to die from the dead
bodies but they were afraid anyway they
bought into the fear so when you look at
this and you see that 2020 has
risen it should actually go down after
2020 there should be a deficit because
you've you pulled people forward they
call it a pull forward effect I hate
that term but I I I say you've cleared
out the dry Tinder right people had
something and they were going to die
anyway over the next six 12 maybe 24
months or they were pulled into that
window of time of 9 weeks when they kind
of weren't cared for the staff didn't
show up at a lot of the old folks ones
if you don't walk a 95 year-old down the
hallway twice a day they can't it
doesn't contract their
calves and and that and push the blood
back up right so if you just say here
wear a mask and lie in bed for two weeks
until we get the staff to walk you
around again they're dead from either
pneumonia or a DBT throwing a clot to a
PE within two weeks
so most of the people that died from
covid it was
neglect and and once all these old
people died then in
21 you have people dying and I'm not
going to say cancer lymph node cancer
specifically but what you have is a
shift of 16 years in the excess deaths
so the excess
deaths were were 81 in 20120 in
Massachusetts and the middle of the
range of excess deaths was 16 years
lower
in 2021 figure that one out and and the
average age of covid death was not in
that
range the average age of covid death in
in 2021 was
75.8 but it was 65 on average of the
excess deaths so people were dying of
not covid something
else 10 years younger and that's a 10x
so you say oh people died from a million
people died from covid well first of all
no they didn't it's about 90 maybe 80 to
90%
fraud and if you actually believe those
numbers and the and the age was
81 and the real age of the excess that
is occurring from not covid let's say a
100,000 of them died let's say only
let's be conservative I'll say a million
but 100,000 of
them but but they died an average of 10
years younger that's 10 times the life
years lost that's a million life years
lost and the people that it
affects when it when I'm sorry but when
an 85-year-old dies you know and I most
of my family is is gone the the the Next
Generation my father was born in 1918 he
cut down trees in the CCC camps in the
Great Depression in New Hampshire
swinging an axe because the saw was too
fast so it's sad when somebody 85 died
but how about a 45y old with three
kids and what pathologies then manifest
in those three children as they grow up
depression drug addiction all kinds of
stuff uh getting back to this I'm trying
to tell you that the 21 and 22 numbers
that you see here that are skyrocketing
and 23 is also very
high it's not on
here the these are these multiply out to
life years's loss that are 10 15 and 20
times that of anything from
Co and I guess I just want to hit one
thing before I finish up um you want me
to finish up right yeah
okay um so before I finish up Kevin
mccaran is um there a lot of graphs
check check them out you guys have this
now keep it
free Kevin mccaran uh managed the Human
Genome Project at MIT for a number of
years he now is the chief science
officer at medicinal genomics in
Massachusetts um he's a world leading
genetics
expert he uh did a DNA sequence of the
vaccines and accidentally found
contamination um in the area of
sequences that cause both oncogenesis so
cancer
promotion and uh tumor suppression
so if you have a way to make cancers
grow faster you got it and if you have a
way to suppress your
ability for those tumors to grow you got
that too um I I don't know that stuff
very well I try to shy away from it but
what you need to know is it's there we
know it's there now not to any degree of
a small amount so your body is if you
get the injections your B the MRNA
injections your body is producing
protein that we don't know what they are
supposed to be the spike protein which
is a glycoprotein right and it resembles
stapo cacus and or toxin B which is a
toxin it also then you hear oh it's
snake venom okay it's not snake venom
but it resembles the protein that is the
toxin that is in snake venom and box
jellyfish and Portuguese manow waren
scorpions and hopa um if you were to
mandate hopter things oh hopter bees
Hornets wasps and red fire ants or hopa
okay let's just say Beast thingss about
20 to 40 people die each year in the
united in the United States from Beast
stings if you were to mandate Beast
stings for everybody 20,000 people would
die in the United States from Beast
thingss so what you have is a death
Lottery that you've mandated upon the
people and so people say well I got it
it didn't hurt me hey good luck to you
you know put another put another chamber
in the revolver put another uh bullet in
the chamber in your revolver spin it now
you get two in there oh three four five
so if your chances are one in a thousand
by the time you take your fifth one it's
five in a thousand I'm not taking that
chance it's a death Lottery that's
another article I wrote moral calculus
of a death Lottery if you want to see
the deductive syllogism of of all that
now so Kevin found the DNA it's in there
and lastly I will say I I I talked about
duties before um so don't take this the
wrong way I mean I sat down with the
Attorney General John promela for 45
minutes with um Representatives um urri
paulov and Jason
Gard that was over a year ago and I
reviewed even more uh New Hampshire
people who died in Massachusetts
hospitals that I had the records of they
were they were they were surprised and
uh when I say they I can't remember the
gentleman's name but the criminal
justice bureau
chief uh they they were kind of of
surprised at what I had where did you
get that I said I have them legally from
Massachusetts I know it's a felony if I
have them from direct directly from New
Hampshire and they were kind of almost
disappointed I think but we had a we had
a a good discussion um I got them to
crack a smile a couple times and in the
end uh um I said I even I even got this
guy to laugh and and they
laughed and then I said and you've been
given notice and you have a legal duty
to act on information and belief that
people are d in New Hampshire from from
this you have a legal duty to
investigate it I don't know what
happened after that so I'm I'm going to
and they walked me out and the smiles
were gone by the way but um so you guys
have a duty to uh make a criminal
referral once you digest this
information I've told you about felonies
that are occurring to New Hampshire
citizens by the
CDC that the HHS Homeland Security is
not going to investigate they don't
investigate their own do not rely on
them you have a duty to the citizens of
New Hampshire whom you
represent so I I would I would say make
a ask the uh attorney general to
petition district judge to immediately
impanel a special grand jury with a
special prosecutor special prosecutor
you use your special prosecutor law if
you want I will I will go through the
New Hampshire law to try to find that
legal path for you to do so um I don't
believe that you can wait to do your
full invest investigation you now know
of Crimes by the CDC and and the
um uh us attorneys are not going to
pursue this the doj is not going to
pursue this they do not investigate
their own and so we we cannot get to a
Federal grand jury but states have their
own grand
juries and you know new New Hampshire n
the grand jury law you have is is not
that great um the the Northwest and
western states have better laws based on
the way they were kind of set up and
founded you know we have really old laws
here that predate our constitution out
west the district judges would come
around like once a year and so they have
the ability to deputize people and they
have Board of County Commissioners that
have certain powers that we don't have
here um but again so have them in
investigate criminal matters that cause
the deaths of thousands of New Hampshire
residents and several hundred thousand
Americans if not more than a million
already so I I I'm Ending by saying
please uh you have that
Duty I hope you'll at least look into it
um attorney generals and again I look at
overall systems Behavior Uh informal
informal political structures within
organizations anyone who is an attorney
general has accepted that position as a
as a politician and that is their uh
career
choice any attorney general that even
attempts to put together an
investigation of Pharma is going to have
the wrath of trillions of dollars
against them and they will never work in
politics
again and this goes for any Red State as
red as you can get they they're they're
afraid their entire career will be
ruined so it takes um you need to box
them in a corner and force them to
impanel a grand jury petition the
district judge make sure it's happened
and you can't use a state attorney
because State Attorneys are also on that
career path that's why a special
prosecutor is so important you bring in
somebody who's retired who cares about
the people of New Hampshire not his own
job and I'm not saying anything bad
about all the New Hampshire State
Attorneys I'm just saying it's a fact
that when when you're in that world you
you you see things through a lens that
is not necessarily for the people but
for your career path and what's good for
you and your family so um please attempt
to do that and you know this a long time
that you've heard me and I really
appreciate it I think
um it was it was tough I've got so much
in my head and I speak for two sometimes
four hours straight from memory I don't
even need all the the the written words
um this is real and it has to be done at
the state and County
levels and the federal government is
killing your
people and it's not an accident thank
you very much for your time does anyone
represent pres
beler thank you madam chair uh thank you
very much for all your testimony this
has been very uh
comprehensive um certainly can't make
any promises as to what we're going to
do or what our report will contain but
we will certainly look at all of these
things and consider them all um I would
like to take a moment if if it's
allowable to speak to uh the committee
and to the public at large um because
we've just heard a lot of things and I
think from my personal perspective I
think some things are are fairly likely
I think other ones may be a little less
likely I'd like to look at them all a
little bit more myself but I do want to
just because I'm sure people heard both
here and at home things today that are
going to challenge them a little bit
maybe they've heard it for the first
time maybe these things even sound a
little bit outlandish to them um so I'd
like to tell you just for a moment about
about a personal experience of mine um
and I can't speak to everything that
we've just
heard uh but I I did receive a single
dose of an mRNA
vaccine
um I was a little skeptical at the time
so I went to the process of being tested
for antibodies to make sure that I
hadn't actually had covid before I
received it I didn't so I went forward I
received the single
dose um within 12 hours I was extremely
sick within 24 to 48 hours I had severe
hypertension roughly 180 over
110 increased heart rate I developed
neurological problems a severe headache
I was hospitalized for the better part
of a week where I nearly died I was
treated with Hein because I was
clotting I developed autoimmune issues I
developed disautonomia I developed heart
problems migraines and seizures among
other things that's not merely my
opinion that is the opinion of the
Physicians who have been treating me
since
2021 now uh this is not as positive for
the rates of these sort of things
happening but I just want people to
understand that some of the things we've
heard today I can verify they're real
and they have happened to some people at
least I can say that when I was
diagnosed originally um there was an odd
thing that happened my neurologist went
to enter the diagnostic code and
discovered that despite for many
vaccines they're being specific
diagnostic codes for a vaccine related
injury or illness for covid vaccine
there was no
code it had to be a generic entry for a
generic vaccine injury or
illness so that's going to provide a
complication I think for us moving
forward in our investigation to try to
determine the frequency of some of these
things
um and the other thing I would say is
we've already read into the record in
this committee and they are our record
people can access that uh some issues
that have been well documented via major
studies in prominent journals that
include uh the Journal of nature mRNA
frame shifting producing random proteins
in a large percentage of cases DNA
contamination particle contamination
issues with the libid nanop particles
mRNA uh located systemically in the body
not merely
locally uh reverse transcription of mRNA
in liver cells Health signals for heart
problems neurological problems as well
as igg4 production uh uh leading to
immune deficiency in some people um so
again I can't this is not just positive
for frequency I just want the people at
home and and elsewhere to understand
that though we've heard some things that
might uh challenge you today I can
verify that at least some of this has
happened in some frequency so I'd like I
I hope we will continue to look into
that and thank
you represent like a
I just I have a question about one of
your graphs I'm
just in the
um first page of graphs that you gave us
of the individual sheets and you were
pointing out the great increases in
2021 but I noticed that for clots and
brains the increases in
2022 and I'm just wondering if you had
any information as to why that might
be you know a lot of these are just my
guesses and I don't like to do that in
testimony you know is it the third shot
is it the you
know I I I put
forth theories I've been told I Was
Wrong by doctors and six months later
they come later they come back and say
oh you were right like I said there's a
pH imbalance in the blood John there
there's there's nothing wrong with it
that that's not happening six months
later a paper comes out this pH
imbalance in the blood and why did I say
that because I had the death
certificates in which there were a lot
of blood and blood forming everything
changed now in my presentation I say so
respiratory excess deaths occurred in
2020 this is Massachusetts okay it's
different for different places New
Hampshire is very different from
Massachusetts I believe that your people
were more honest in filling out death
certificates I really believe that
um so respiratory in 2020 it shifted to
circulatory and blood in 2021 and then
you have acute problems like you know
endothelial scoring uh through apoptosis
by transection and then you have t- cell
attack of parts of your endothelium so
if you take a direct vein injection like
Mark jiro's ballis Theory
um it there's a chance maybe 150 maybe
200 we don't know but it's it's in that
range uh if the tip of the needle is
near a vein you're going to take a a
vein hit where the blood is returning
right so it's returning but you take a
whole bunch all at once and it goes to
like one place and through fluid
dynamics I think that they tend to
aggregate where um when when you get to
the edge of something where fluid flows
through it slows down so that the
theoretically the air at your windshield
is not moving but it gets compressed but
there's certain molecules that are just
sitting there right um and if it all
gets all all that mRNA goes to one
place that's where I believe the aortic
dissections are occurring and um you get
a whole balloon threeyear aorta why I
mean is that normal no no people
have problems excuse me people have
problems for a long time that then
manifest in an aortic dissection they
don't just get a shot and then you know
a week later they're dead like um like
Victor s you know he's from New York
moved to Washington he's in here you
read his about the aortic aortic
dissection and you look in the Minnesota
data aortic dissection
so I'm sorry I'm not answering your
question I I just don't don't know how
to answer it but that's fine thank
youle
off thank you Madame chair and thank you
for presenting it and taking my question
so you talk about different uh risk
factors that uh looks like they contri
contributed to that excessive death that
we are seen you talked about lack of
care you talked about ventilators you
talked about covid vaccines and you
talked about vular REM and we already
heard about most of it but you also
mentioned when commits in so I just
wonder if you can follow up and later
send us send the committee some
documents about when Comm and uh if the
what are concerns about the drug what
are side effects uh from Van possible
yeah it's uh representative paulov vany
is is pretty commonly used um and and
it's known that in overdose situations
it causes kidney failure there's plenty
of papers on it I I can't provide you
any more than you could do by just
typing it in Duck
ducko rather than that other search
company that is against the
people so and you you'd probably know
more about vamis than I
would represent beler and then represent
leus thank you madam chair and I was
going to wait a little later on this but
I'd like to just quickly read one item
into the record which I will provide a
bit later um study available from the uh
NIH website from December 2022 titled to
aspirate or to not aspirate
considerations for covid-19 vaccines in
which the abstract goes on to explain
that despite it being um common practice
for a very long time it was not
recommended that aspiration occur with
covid-19 vaccination for some reason and
to describe what that is uh when you
when you do an intramuscular injection
they you're trying well you're trying to
put it the drug into the musculature
which is where it's then supposed to
remain for the most part but obviously
within your body there's not just muscle
even within the muscular there are veins
and there are arteries there's actually
a loop that goes around the the tip of
the hum
that's an artery that can be hit um so
typically when you're trained to
administer an intramuscular vaccine you
insert the needle and then you pull back
on the plunger which is aspiration to
see if you get blood which would
indicate you're in a blood vessel rather
than a muscle uh again the study goes on
to explain that this was not recommended
for the covid-19 vaccine so that's
another angle that we'll probably want
to take a look at thank
you may I comment on that sure okay so
the CDC puts out the pink
book it's about what he just said and it
was put out uh by two
nurses and in the pink book they say Do
not aspirate because needle wiggle may
cause
discomfort they further say in the
paragraph that they have no scientific
basis for this they just feel that the
patient would be more comfortable if
you inject
quickly not not not just not aspirate
but also inject quickly which another
thing like Mark jirau says inject very
slowly and you'll have a lot less lot
fewer people dying so where did that
come from it came look look up the pink
book if you buy my book you just look at
the references and it's in there um and
that's online under the CDC that's where
that came from and there's no scientific
basis for not doing what was custom and
practice prior to co so they're killing
a lot of people simply by ball injection
and it doesn't even mean matter if it's
the covid vaccine that if you do that
with the flu vaccine or any others
you'll see deaths rise you'll see
anything that transfects cells anything
that's going to be you know you're
bypassing your mucosal defenses how do
things get in your body you put them in
your body or you're taking it in through
the air your lungs have very strong
mucosal defenses you're bypassing that
by going directly into your body with an
injection of stuff you don't even know
what it is with the manufacturing
controls that are so terrible as there
contamination but one one other thing I
wanted to mention um with some of the
smaller ones when you do aspirate you
have immediate
Collapse by through the the D the
physics of it and because you collapse
it it pulls it through the other side
now you're out you're not in the vein
anymore either so aspiration alone uh
isn't foolproof but it's it's another
measure that helps so yeah I'm really
glad you brought that up
thanks yes
going back
um to
earlier and you had commented that there
was enough information within months to
shut down shut down the whole process
from the um deaths that
happened same day you know 11 deaths you
said happen the same day so I'm
wondering what is
normal as a
comparison J okay so um that comment was
in the context of looking at vs the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
which was put in place for it it was to
appease the antix crowd years
ago I think it's a terrible system but
it's what we have and as bad as it is
the signal and I say the signal right so
what is normal um the problem with
saying oh all these things are now in in
bears that are so much more than before
the
my easy counterargument was yeah people
are a lot more aware aware of this
vaccine and so they're going crazy
making Bears reports where they didn't
make reports before you you can always
come up with an excuse one side versus
the other but when you look at the
number of deaths and and so what I did
is I went in and I correlated the death
certificates to the vers report so I
know the person actually died it's not a
BS Report these people really died and I
got their injection dates and I know
what they died from they didn't die from
pneumonia they didn't die from covid
they died from a pulmonary embolism they
died from throm cytopenia post
hemorrhagic anemia did you see the PO go
when you're done just remember post
hemorrhagic anemia take a look at that
one now Cardiac
Arrest writing the paper on it now um
there's a major bug in the entire CDC
excuse me wh system and the CDC of how
to categorize cardiac arrest uh I I
don't have time to explain it right now
but the entire system is is messed up um
so you have scientific papers being
written on data that's it's not
fraudulent it's it's errant it lacks
integrity and understanding of what a
cardiac arrest is you know what Cardiac
Arrest means think of the word the heart
stopped okay the guy got covid then he
got pneumonia then he died of
cardiopulmonary arrest and it gets
listed as heart disease it doesn't it
and it's 16 to
19% of all deaths in Massachusetts have
i46 sorry to devate but
I any other
questions you know I can talk for four
hours PS off it's not a question but
follow up I I want to um I want some
time to submit uh uh several papers to
the record and share it with the
committee here to discuss after lunch
break if now is a good time okay
uh unless somebody else have a question
to the presenter does anyone else have
any
questions okay does anyone need a five
minute
break okay let's take a f minute break
and then maybe you can start uh reading
your papers okay uh and I'd like to
thank you so much for being here I
appreciate it um thank thank you for the
time thank you very much for having me
really appreciate the voice I will bring
these up to you and then I'm done right
you are all right thank you out to the
rain
again thank
you
e
e e
um if I could get everyone to take their
seat uh so we can uh break for lunch
shortly representative
beler uh representative H off you wanted
to uh introduce something into the
record yeah yeah yes there's a like uh F
five uh five pages I want to introduce
to record so um in previous session we
heard a lot that um from specialist that
kids are not uh the target vulnerable
population for covid and those measures
are misapplied when applied for kids but
is there any data to back it up so I
looked it up and that's what I found so
if you go an hdhhs visit data on minor
covid death uh 2020 2024 ages 0 to9 you
will find that for all this Co years
there's only a single death for that
population on the other side of that
paper ages 10 to 19 uh how
many uh New Hampshire uh residents in
that age died from covid zero zero so in
total under 19 years old uh only only
only single Des
documented uh and if you go to the next
one uh name is CDC whiskers New
Hampshire caes of this
data uh so uh it's a little bit small
font so if you turn it around uh I
multip uh there's a better view of Ages
1 to 4 and you can see uh number four uh
cause of death for that ages uh
for uh uh is uh uh pretty long it's
combination of covid-19 diabetes melus
heart disease influenza pneumonia and
septicemia and why this specific
combination as as you saw in previous
document it's because there was only one
case and that one case uh was actually
specific New Hampshire resident that was
already dying from diabetes heart
disease flu Etc but also was tested
positive for Co So Co listed as a
primary uh death and as that person died
not in New Hampshire hospital but
outside and you you heard from previous
presenter that that might be the reason
why Co and not for example diabetes was
listed because those states are not as
uh
accurate and kind of overstated number
of deaths but even with that like so for
all this years there's only a single kid
who died from covid official data from
CDC and
DHHS and uh and uh that that picture was
combined not by some republ an it's bami
uh pretty ultr left organization so it's
it's it's a nonpartisan agreement that
that's what happened and the last one is
U uh query from uh virus the vaccine
adverse event Reporting System results
uh so I query several age ranges for New
Hampshire resident
under
17 uh up to 18 years
uh uh and
uh and uh those of them who died so you
can see that there are uh four four New
Hampshire residents uh and uh multiple
awful symptoms that went after they took
covid-19 vaccines uh for those people
and uh being on house Health uh Human
Services and elderly Affairs committee
everyone on our committee knows that
uh the number of reports the reports to
virus database are severely under
reported many many injuries and deaths
don't end up being here so but even with
that we see
that in New
Hampshire not the single otherwise
healthy kid died from covid but a number
of kid died uh after receiving covid-19
vaccine and I think it's very concerning
thank you thank you represent POA uh
we'll get that into the record um uh to
continue our discussion from earlier
today discuss some uh questions that we
have and
uh what we want for this committee I'd
like to continue that discussion does
anyone have anything specific represent
evil thank you madam chair I was sort of
uh thinking about the federal funds
issue in particular and I just made some
notes um maybe we could get a timeline
like we have for the covid vaccine roll
out for the federal funds
identify um where they were coming from
and and how they started to be
distributed maybe zero in on the amount
of money the process of distrib
distribution to whom it was distributed
and and whether uh or how the use of the
funds was was tracked and then maybe if
there's some uh measures of success so I
think that uh maybe Taylor Caswell can
help us with that and then I know that
there is on some State websites a
listing of how the funds were
distributed so I don't think that should
take a lot of extra accounting from him
and then we could sort of look at the
federal funds that were used for health
orientation kind of a thing and then I
know many funds were used for for
infrastructure so I don't know how other
people feel about that but that seemed
like if we were going to uh talk to
Taylor Caswell that might be a way of
focusing the discussion I I think that's
a great idea and I like the idea of
focusing on on the successes um I think
it's important uh that not only we find
what the issues are but we really need
to find out what we did well in New
Hampshire
um because I think like and even uh our
former speaker said that New Hampshire
got he thought we got some of the things
right um
and uh you know so I think that we need
you know we didn't follow everything
that every other state did and I think
that's a plus for us and so I think also
looking at our successes to see what we
did right is also important to highlight
in the in the report um so I don't know
if anyone else has any other questions
um I do know I have sent an email to uh
commissioner Caswell um to see his
availability I'm still waiting to hear
back I'm hoping to hear back from
director buckton also of their
availability I mean you know I think
where we're not meeting I mean Fridays
does seem to be an okay day for most of
us but if we have to change our day uh
to accommodate these folks um I would
definitely give the committee a heads up
but I think um because we really want to
hear from them and we also want to hear
from Dr Chan that we need to maybe
accommodate their schedules also um well
and I I remember when we spoke to the
speaker he said you know after crossover
one of the limiting factors was all our
work but the other thing was the um the
availability of meeting rooms he said
maybe after crossover there would we'd
have a little bit more latitude um and I
think he mentioned Wednesday or you and
I uh talk I know you have a work
schedule though everybody's got their
schedules um if you want I was just
going to offer I could just dash off a
few of these things that I just said for
you and then that way if you wanted to
change it or whatever you could send it
to commissioner C sure if you would like
to and if anybody has any questions that
we've discussed if you just want to
email them to me then I will forward
them on I think it you know that way uh
it'll be in one central place and it
will just make it easier um that way and
we're not being duplicative of the
questions we're asking
um so does anyone else have anything
else that we need to look at but I agree
with uh you representative Eble I think
that uh we need to look at the
monies I actually have a so then the
other person is the homeland security
director so I mean obviously we should
ask him about his the current
preparation of the report what they're
looking at what the status is and then
um I mean
hard to know exactly what to ask him I
think well maybe we'll say we're our
Focus from our mission is a special look
at at health I don't know um um what I
have done when I have emailed these uh
these folks is I am actually giving them
a copy what of what our mission
statement is so they have an
understanding of what this committee is
um and I think it's important that they
have that um uh so that is what I am
doing just so there it's not a oh what
is this committee so represent like us I
didn't think we were just health I
thought we were oh education yeah
because that's that's a big that it had
a huge effect on education trying to
remember that I couldn't hear without
microphone it's a little bit loud in
this
corner represent leus was saying we
don't want to just focus on health we
want to focus on the educational aspect
um but but I do believe that the two go
hand in hand because with the shutdown
of schools it affected the you know we
we're dealing with mental health issues
and other health things which in turn
and also you know looking at air
filtration systems and even ongoing to
make sure that our schools have the
proper air air filtration systems in
them uh for any
upcoming pandemic or even the flu season
um to help mitigate those I think is an
important um thing to look at that that
would be an advantage of this committee
is that speak micophone that would be an
advantage to this committee is that
things that we find that are helpful
that would have been helpful or that
were helpful in
covid-19 is they can be used for lots of
other issues like the flu because that's
that takes out huge numbers of kids and
teachers every year flu season and so if
they get the
proper if they get a nice system that's
going to would have worked or did work
for
covid and they use the co monies for
that yes that continues on and keeps
that mayate the flu season right I'm not
saying that it's going to eliminate it
but it could possibly help and I'm you
know but the flu could act completely
different than Co and that's it's the
other thing we just don't know
everything represent Vil yeah I found
the um email that we got from Trisha
Tilly on what the homeland security
report was going to cover so it was
preparedness command communication
decision making financial management so
that is also federal funds right um and
other and then health and medical
Logistics private Public Partnerships
and public information so so
um I think financial management and
health and medical I mean I do think the
education piece sort of feeds into
health because what they were doing was
because of health reasons right ex so I
mean anyway that's what he's uh that's
what he's covering so I don't know if we
want to select out some of those were
particularly interested in or if you
just want to have him come in and talk
well I think um I mean private Public
Partnerships not sure we'll dive deep in
that represent
leus yeah I have and I can make copies
if people are interested but um the
Indiana attorney general did a report
that's sort of a subset maybe of what
we're doing just to see what they did
and what questions were asked and what
information they got it's the analysis
of covid-19 positivity rate data and
death stati statistics and the soci
economic impact of covid-19 mitigation
policies and so I can make everybody a
copy of this if you're interested or you
can just look at it get it up on yeah we
can do that I got it I got maybe there's
just a link you oh there I can do that
because this came from a link and we and
if you could send the link we can get uh
uh it up on our website okay thank
you uh but if anyone wants a copy please
let represent vus know uh represent
belch thank you madam chair I just I
just wanted to make a a a quick um
argument Point regarding the um the
upcoming DHHS report that we are going
to be receiving and looking at um just
just for clarification it's Homeland
Security oh yes my apologies yes so the
report that we're going to be looking at
and receiving is going to come from the
executive Branch obviously with our form
of government the three branches of
government we have each other in check
and we have a responsibility to um to
keep each other in check in the various
ways that were delegated To Us by the
Constitution um as such I think it's
very important that we look at this
report as a very good thing that we can
utilize in our efforts here um as a part
of what we're doing but it's also at the
same time very important to not look at
it as
dispositive and simply um file it away
and say Yep this is this is what it is
it's it's very important for us to
anything that we find uh important in
our in our goals here to verify the
veracity of it uh which may mean
duplicating efforts but that that is
just part of our I think responsibility
from the legislative side uh well I
think that the timing of the report
which will be out is supposed to be out
according to
um Miss Tilly uh is the end of June um
we will not be meeting in July or August
so that will give us a chance to uh
preview the report and um when we come
back in the fall maybe have uh if we
have any questions we can uh address
them then
um that if you think that there's
something that we've just discovered
that report differs from or if the what
the positives in the report are that we
agree with I mean I think it's important
um not to also look for the
positives so um uh Trisha Tilly did
write us a a email to see if we had more
questions for her and I didn't know if
there had been any response to that or
if we have something more so I did send
off a list of question questions to her
I was LAX in getting those questions to
her so I would give her some latitude in
getting them back to her to us but I
also believe that some of the questions
May Beyond her purview um and I let her
know as such that if she thought they
were and maybe if she knew who they
could be directed to to let let me know
um did you share the question I can
absolutely share the qu the email that I
sent to uh Miss Tilly thank you you're
welcome
does anyone else have anything else if
not uh we'll adjourn for lunch and we
will be back here at 1 p.m. I apologize
I can't I understand and I hope anyone
everyone be safe that's leaving on the
roads um it's a rainy one take
care
e
e e
good afternoon everyone I'm going to
open up uh the afternoon session on for
the special committee for Co
response and um I would like to ask uh
if anyone from the public would like to
come up and
speak uh please introduce yourself your
name where you're from and uh tell us
what you want us to hear
okay uh good afternoon uh thank you for
having me here today um my name is Tara
hay and I live in Brentwood New
Hampshire uh with my husband and my two
daughters um I'm here today to talk
about our experience with covid and
specifically around the reaction from
school
how that impacted our family and then on
to the vaccine covid vaccine and the
reactions that we had on August 4th 2021
my youngest daughter who is now 20 was
injured by the covid vaccine a vaccine
that she did not want to get but had to
in order to attend college to achieve
her goal of becoming a medical
professional
um just to tell you a little bit about
my daughter she was 16 and a junior in
high school when covid started when the
schools shut down um she was wrapping up
her or starting to wrap up her junior
year college
applications um she had just bought her
junior prom dress and she bought heels
for the prom and the heels were a big
deal for her because she has had a
chronic p pain condition that started
when she was 12 years old but she
overcame it and so for her that
purchasing of a
prom buying heels that she could go to
her prom with was a big
deal um so she'd overcame The Chronic
pain disease her leg hurt but she could
function nobody knew that she wasn't she
was competing gymnastics at her High
School uh she was also doing competitive
gymnastics at one of the local Club
Gymnastics
facilities uh she also competed
nationally as a competitive jump roper
doing events like speed and double dutch
and whole variety of things so she was a
really active active kid um she'd always
been active you know her things to do
were jump on the trampoline do flips
yoga hang out with friends hiking all of
that stuff um I don't know if you're
interested but I for instance I have a
picture of her summer of
2020 hiking Mount Major um at the top of
it just so excited to be standing at the
top of the mountain um because she could
um it was
fantastic um when Co first hit the
school things were tough and shut down
you know at first we really understood
it we you know two weeks it made sense
let's do this was our in our mind but
then as more and more data came
out it wasn't making sense to keep these
kids out of school um my oldest she was
a freshman in college at the time she
came home from college in March of 2020
and did not go back that year um while
she was home taking classes remotely for
the remainder of ref freshman year and
all of her sophomore year she was a
Frontline worker at a
supermarket um and at that
point we were like why is it that she
can go day in day out serve hundreds of
customers people she doesn't know but
she can't go sit in a classroom with her
peers and and learn and get her
education
um so again as more and more data came
out it started to become clear that
younger healthy people were at minimal
risk of
severe reaction severe cases of
covid um we knew that it was individuals
with comorbidities we knew that it was a
lot of elderly um but our young were
pretty
safe um in the summer
2020 our local K through2 School
District came out and sent a survey to
All Families asking whether we wanted
our children to go back to school in
person for fall of
2020 the results showed that 80% of the
families in the school district wanted
their kids to be back in school in
person then we were told that wasn't
happening it was too dangerous for these
kids to be back in
school we needed to protect them they
were told they couldn't have all those
kids in the middle and high school and
still be able to keep the 6 foot social
distancing
policy if you don't mind I'm I'm sorry
to interrupt and I know this is is
difficult so I have a couple questions
of what you just said is one 80% of
parents I want to make sure I understand
this 80%
so more than well more than half of the
families wanted their kids back in
school and they felt that it would be a
safe environment is this correct correct
my other question to you is you
mentioned the social distancing the six
foot did they ever talk about
why they where they came up with that
guidance or why they needed it to be 6
feet I'm just curious my understanding
is it came from fouchy
um that was the number that he had and
the NIH had stated was the appropriate
number today there is information and
that has come out that says that was a
guess that was not fact based on any
factual or scientific data however that
was the number that was used in order
for the kids to go back to school safely
thank you I'm sorry to interrupt but I
just wanted to clarify
that's fine representative
Penza So based upon just kind of
following up on what um uh
representative ktoa asked so when school
guidance came out it was just like in a
sense not giving any reasons it was kind
of like we're doing what we're
told like CDC guidance that kind of
thing like if people questioned it was
it did they get just a kind of a canned
response for people that did question
when we did question when questions were
asked it went back to the CDC guidance
was what they utilized to make their
decisions um there was at later times
they looked at um rate Community rate
hospitalization um then vaccination like
when could teachers be
vaccinated um all of that
information um and I'll speak to it
later but they the feeling from our
perspective is that the bar kept moving
and that created a an entire environment
of
uncertainty and pressure on families but
more importantly on the kids and the
students because they were told one
thing when we met that it was
changed um and the bar would be moved
out further and so it became very
difficult to have a good understanding
of when they would be back in school and
what that would look like quick followup
go ahead representative
so you know before I was a
representative this was I was in this uh
kind of uh space kind of fighting
against all this uh stuff and um and I
received the guidance um that came out
and I was just wondering as a parent
because my girls were not in a public
school at the time and um
but so for example I got I got the
guidance from districts that were right
next door to you big districts like a
Portsmith and stuff that had you know it
was kind of like think of it all like on
an Excel spreadsheet but did you get
that with the red and the green and okay
so you had all they and but they kept
you got that to at the beginning no oh
okay that piece came out and again
please forgive me in my recollection
here but that came out later um in the
spring when they started saying okay so
the first part of it was we don't have
enough room for all of the students to
come back to the school based on the six
foot social
distancing so that was the first reason
that they could not do it um again
despite 80% of families saying this is
what we wanted um there was one local
elementary school um in Brentwood suy
that did go back in person and they
found a way to make it work where kids
that wanted to stay home were able to do
a remote with their teachers and the
kids that wanted to be in person were
able to be in person from day one um
starting back in Fall of
2020 that worked well I don't know how
you know it would be great if someone
could track the impact of the kids that
were in person versus remote on that you
your District was one I I believe my
recollection was one of the ones that
was at either at the last or was forced
by the governor to open correct we were
forced by the governor thank you
yep and I will talk about that
because that is one of the things that
really impacted my daughter is this
yo-yoing um you
know again these kids after they were
told the middle in the high school
didn't have enough room for six foot
distancing I believe it was November the
guidance changed and they dropped it to
feet at that point again people were
excited thinking okay now perhaps we'll
get back to
school again the high school and the
middle school they said it was too
complicated to get those kids back in
school the middle of the year um may I
ask who is making that decision was it
the school administration or the school
board it was a combination I believe it
was being presented to them by the
administration but the school board
seemed to go along with all of the rec
recommendations that were coming down
from the school administration thank you
yeah
um so pretty much after my kids had this
summer where they were doing competitive
Sports they were interacting they were
living life they were then told you know
you were going to be remote again um you
know and at that
point you know they they ended up going
back to school
online in their bedrooms by
themselves it was my youngest her senior
year and that's how it started um so
then I mentioned in November there was I
believe it was November the social
distancing changed from six feet to 3
feet but that still wasn't enough to get
us back middle of the term too difficult
um too hard to make that
happen around that time what we did not
know until after the fact is that the
school
administration signed and and the school
board signed
anou with the teachers union that
prohibited the ability to do hybrid
learning
um just for my
clarification could you please repeat
did you just say that over the request
of parents in for the benefit of the
students the school administration and
the school board went against 80% of the
population and signed a memorandum of
understanding with the teachers union
that said that you could only go back if
it was full-time and not a
full-time um some full-time and some
remote is that correct at the beg at the
end of the summer there was a survey to
parents and 80% of the parents surveyed
wanted their children back in school in
person come November December and I
would have to go back and look at the
specific dates and the emails because I
have them um they
changed and started saying we could not
go back in the middle of a
term they also started talking about the
rate of covid having increased again so
that perhaps the surveys that were done
in the summer were no longer relevant
because now there was a higher rate of
covid than there was at the beginning of
the school
year they also at that time signed anou
with the teachers
union that
stated that there would not be hybrid
they would not be required to teach a
hybrid class
which meant all classes had to be either
100% in person or 100%
remote this becomes
important
when January comes along and we are told
that our kids could go back to school in
person if they would
like so my daughter a senior wants to go
back to to school in
person I then find
out that
unfortunately and a lot of the seniors
if you are taking AP classes if you are
taking honors classes if you
are
um if you are taking a highlevel
language class high level math class
anyone where there might not be multiple
sessions of that
classes you would still be
remote you could go into the school and
you could zoom from the band room the
cafeteria the gymnasium wherever you
were
assigned but you were sitting in there
with a number of other students that
were all taking different classes and
you would zoom into your classroom while
the teacher was in the classroom and you
were not the students were
not I just need to kind of wrap my head
around this a little bit um because it
sounds very convoluted to me however so
what you're saying is anybody in a high
level
class who would have to go to the
school and sit in an empty classroom
with other kids in that school and the
teacher would be remote no not quite if
you were in a high level class class and
there might only be one session of that
class offered and there were students
who opted for
remote and there were students who opted
for in
person because of theou that was
signed they could not offer hybrid so
that the student that wanted to be
remote could Di into the classroom and
the rest of the students could be in the
room with the classroom with the teacher
because of that the school solution to
that was to assign the kids that were
inperson
remote to a location within the school
building for instance the band
room it might be the cafeteria so they
would be assigned to a location within
the school building while the teacher
would be sitting in the classroom by
themselves and the students would dial
in through Zoom from whatever room they
were in in the school while the teachers
taught fully remotely so let me just
rephrase what you just said and see if I
understand this the teacher was actually
in the building but because of a
memorandum of understanding with the
teach teachers
union e that those students could not be
in the same classroom as the teacher
because there were some students that
were remote is that correct correct and
again I'm the teacher I guess since they
were remote for that class they could be
teaching it from anywhere I use that
they might have been in the classroom
because they so they could have been at
the beach for all you
know I'm just being fous yes but from
anywhere okay thank you representative
beler thank you madam chair I just want
to drill a little bit of that too
because I want to I think I
understand the issue and I want to draw
a good distinction just to make
sure
um because I I can I can just playing
Devil's Advocate I can imagine a
scenario where because remote is a
different thing than in person maybe a
teacher gets assigned to a room the size
of a broom closet to be
remote and there's no room for students
but I want to be clear that's that's not
what was happening if they were in there
they were actually in a classroom where
there were seats and they just didn't
occupy them I have to tell you that I
can't tell you where the teachers were
physically I can tell you where the
students
were um that the students were remote
well I guess I guess there's another way
I could ask this which is the the the
rational for doing this had nothing to
do with whether or not the student
students could be accommodated in a
classroom that was equipped for Zoom but
rather solely because of a memorandum of
understanding that is my understanding
thank
you
yeah any okay
um
so again forgive me I'm trying to make
sure I'm
staying okay um so as I said the we felt
like the bar kept moving January she put
down that she wanted to go in person and
then we found out her classes would be
remote there were kids doing classes
from their cars there were kids doing
classes from coffee shops there were
kids doing classes from home there were
kids driving between home and school
because they had one remote and one in
person it it was there was a lot that
went on at that time um so for after the
excitement of potentially going back to
school it was a let down for my senior
to find out that it wasn't going to be
that way for her so she decided to
remain remote because she could not
study in she couldn't zoom in and listen
from a band room while there were other
kids taking different classes around her
um so she ended up remaining remote at
the high school until the governor told
the schools they had to go back in
person in
April represent
Penza um just a quick question about
that
so in trying to understand so they
opened up the school which even though
it was fully remote like you said and
she decided that she wasn't going to do
that because it wasn't really going back
and um so did they do all of the
protocols like so for I know it was Bare
Bones in a lot of these schools when
they did open up because I know a couple
did this same thing that you're talking
about so was it barebone staff there
pretty much um and then PE kids were
assigned to certain rooms you might not
know this so I was going to say I can't
answer that what I can say though is
there were classes that did take place
in person so it wasn't 100% remote when
the school opened up okay it was only
those classes that they had students
that wanted to be both remote and they
had students that wanted to be in person
and that they could not move them to
another section of the class they
couldn't do both
they because they like so if you and let
me give you an example if you were
taking freshman English there might be
20 or more freshman English classes so
if you have 80% that want to be in
person and 20% that don't they can find
a way to move students around so that
the 80% could be in person for that
freshman English class and the 20% could
be in a different class
remote however when you talk about about
you know honors physics can't do that
you don't have that flexibility and that
option to do that and so that's why it
tended to impact the upper classman I
believe more than the the lower grade
were you familiar like when when you're
um when you expressed that you wanted to
go back and she was excited in January
if those were underneath all of the you
know we're still going to operate under
3 feet um you're going to be required to
Mar mask all that all those protocols
were still hardcore in place right yes
and they had the hallways directional
yes um so yeah I've been to I I was
there in the High School uh multiple
times during that and so yeah that the
signs were everywhere they were on the
floors walls all of that exactly okay
thank
you can you likeus thank you can you
tell me how they did an honors physics
class remote
so great
question
um my
daughter
was having by this point she was
starting to
struggle in class um one of the things
that I had done when I heard that the
school was not going to be open in the
fall I looked online and then said if
she needs to take classes why not have
her take classes where she gets college
credit so she took two classes from
Great Bay Community College she took
classes at the SEO School of Technology
where she earned her
LNA and she took two classes at exor
high
school those two classes that she took
at the exor high
school were
the stress that those were the ones
there was no understanding of what was
going on there was confusion there was
it was challenging it was
frustrating it
was there were no set
expectations it it was those caused
her anxiety and
stress and at one point I reached out to
the school and I said she will no longer
be attending the classes because this is
not um and she took a break from
attending the online classes and we
figured out how for how she could get
the information and learn on her own
thank you it so no you couldn't learn
honors physics online
yeah um all right so um she went to
those online classes she obtained her
LNA as I mentioned her senior year which
that was challenging because um it was
really hard to get
clinicals and but they managed to do it
at the very end of her senior year and
she was actually able to pass the
licensing exam in the spring of 21 right
before
graduation
um she as I said my daughter was a
gymnast um she had to wear a mask for
high school gymnastics yet she could go
to Club Gymnastics and and that was no
mask um imagine being a gymnast on the
beam or on the bars and your mask
slips um you know it was it was
interesting they started then getting to
the point where you could hang your mask
on the apparatus or hand it to your
coach before you got on to did your aent
and then your coach would hand it back
to you which was very
sanitary um and made made a lot
of so so those were the things that she
was dealing with um it
was you know we had friends that played
tennis they had to play tennis with
masks on while their opponent was across
the net um so there just seemed to be
this trying to understand trying to help
us make it make sense and feeling like
we weren't getting
we weren't looking out for our kids the
decisions that were being made were not
in the best interest of the kids in my
opinion um we felt like covid kept being
held over their head and that the bar
for when life could become normal for
them kept
moving
um then they were told after the January
attempt to go back to school in person
for my daughter some were able to um
they were then told that school could go
back to
normal when teachers had had the
opportunity to get
vaccinated and that once the teachers
all the teacher categories were
vaccinated one month after that because
that would allow them to get their two
shots and or whatever the time frame was
I can't remember then we could go back
to school that was the next thing
then it became the handout with the
spreadsheet that talked about
hospitalizations and Community rates of
covid and based on those charts then we
could or couldn't go back to school um
we went through all of that so then
after we were told about the
vaccinations and that the
teachers you know as they got to be
vaccinated the conversation at school
became are you
vaccinated teachers were asking students
were asking it became a common question
for everybody are you vaccinated are you
getting vaccinated when are you getting
vaccinated to the point where the school
had to send a notice out stating that
that was not an appropriate topic or
question to be asked of
students so again my daughter's feeling
a lot of pressure about
I need to get
vaccinated so then they went from there
and they told them that they could have
their senior
prom and that was big news that was
exciting happy it was going to be held
in the parking lot
outside
um and they would have to wear
masks if they were
unvaccinated along with a list of other
requirements there would be social whole
variety whole list of things uh first um
just a quick question for you I thought
you just said that something came down
from the administration that asking
students or anyone if they were
vaccinated was inappropriate is that
correct yes so how could they
ask students that weren't vaccinated to
wear mask and how would they know who
wasn't vaccinated
um if asking that question was
inappropriate that just seems to me
duplicitous that was a great question
and um the students were asked to
provide their vaccination
card when they checked in for prom that
evening I just need to clarify something
again and I'm I'm sorry if I'm being
repetitive the administ
ation sent out a memo to school
officials s saying that asking if a
student is vaccinated was inappropriate
is that correct in the school
environment correct in the school
environment was not the prom considered
being in the school environment the prom
was not a right it was an
activity it's but but it is still
associated with the school is it
not in my mind yes however I was not the
one making the decisions thank you and
who may I ask who made that decision was
it the school administration or the
school board so I have an article that I
brought with me on oops that's not it um
I have an article that I brought with me
from the SE coast online that says EHS
Administration aware of plan to Mark oh
I haven't spoken about the market of the
vaccinated students yet but I will um
EHS Administration aware of plan to Mark
students at the prom sau6 superintendent
says this was on July 28th
2021 okay so just following up on this
so the administration was aware of
it but the and the superintendent was
also aware of it but it doesn't say
who's taking responsibility
there so I'm just so let me let me back
up one minute yeah um because to fully
understand what occurred and why I don't
have those
answers um so my daughter showed up to
the
prom we did she BR did not have a
vaccination card because she was not
vaccinated um when she showed up to the
prom they had decided they would Mark
and number the hands of the students who
were not vaccinated and they tracked
that on a
document that the parent volunteers I
believe were responsible
for they
then went into the prom and there were
underclassmen who were recording after
every three songs the students would
raise their hand up
and they would record the numbers of the
students with markings on their hand so
that they could M keep track of where
you were and who you were
with
so representative
Penza okay so I want to go back real
quick to the guidance okay because I I
do know this pretty well and I'd like
you just to confirm so
so most of the guidance that was coming
out I know of in another district and I
believe it was in your District as well
guidance was given out directly to the
students through their email addresses
sometimes even bypassing the parents in
regards with these protocols right
pushing with vaccines and Clinics and
all of these types of things that were
happening and then um through them kind
of in a sense getting slapped is when
then the administration sent out a
blanket message to say you know oh sorry
we screwed up correct that's how my
understanding okay and I know where that
guidance came from and I'm going to
provide that to the committee I have all
of that information but if you have all
of those emails that would be extremely
helpful um I have a bunch of emails from
another district and I think it would be
very good because of similar but still
different yeah um you know and then the
other piece is um in
a lot of this came from peers feeling
this stuff and and of course possibly
even teachers or administrators saying
these things like off the cuff up which
they never should but in in no time
anybody ever talked about um medical
privacy or any of these types of things
none of this stuff ever came up right
everybody was wanting to know their
status correct and
um yeah correct you know and that was
one of the things that I you know wanted
to specify here was that when she went
to the
prom she was excited to go she was
unvaccinated and the guidance had been
that she would have to wear a mask so
she had actually had her
grandmother who trimmed her who hemmed
her dress making matching mask out of
the bottom of her prom dress because
that's that's healthy I mean
that's um so she had a matching mask
created from the bottom of her dress
that she could wear since she was
unvaccinated um what had happened though
is right before the prom The Mask
mandate was
dropped which is why they made this
decision to Mark to number them
and that decision I never received any
notification that that was happening we
went to the um like the prominade where
the students all walk by all the parents
and we cheer for them and everything and
I noticed that there was um this black
staining on my daughter and I said
what's that from and she goes oh wait
till you hear and she told that was how
I found out that they were planning on
doing this so
that was just one more kind of blow to
her
of you know she was being marked based
on her medical
decisions represent
Penza okay so when that it's very
interesting because it I remember the
timing and dates wise so at the same
time that guidance came out which
slapped all of the schools about this
specifically you know creating two
classes of students and all of that kind
of stuff the most important thing that
was sent to every single
superintendent um every single
superintendent every single School Board
in the entire State and all of that
information should have came down like
where you heard the guidance this is
from from the Department of Education
which you know came specifically from
their
lawyer um so you didn't get that
directly you only got a secondhand oh we
can't do that anymore correct yes
the the other thing that had
happened was because there was such a
thing made about vaccinated versus
unvaccinated it almost became as you
said that second class
um you couldn't get invited to things if
you weren't vaccinated some parents
wanted proof of vaccination to go to
prom
parties um so it just it kind of rolled
and it became bigger and bigger once the
students start feeling like oh well
everyone's telling us you should get
vaccinated you're not that's not safe I
don't know if you can come so it almost
sounds like a form of
discrimination would you say that uh
based on what you're telling me um that
people are actually discriminating
against people that were not vaccinated
is that correct against students that
aren't vaccinated I felt that my
daughter was treated
differently um I felt that it's a form
of pressure bullying har you know that's
what I felt was happening there was this
pressure that you need to do this you
need to do this um and it was pretty
clear what the message was get
vaccinated or be left
behind and and did you and do you feel
that that that message was um more from
her peers or from just the public in
general I think that message was from
everywhere even even
today you
know two days ago I walked into
Walgreens and I took a whole bunch of
photos because everywhere you
look get your vaccination free
vaccination have a
vaccination all of this information
about every vaccine under the and not
one place does it
specify what the potential risks are
it's beautiful marketing it's beautiful
information for people to get it hey
it's free a lot of you can get it for
free um but there's nothing on those
marketing materials that tell
you here's the potential side effects
here's the things you might want to
think about before you get this
represented
Penza do you recall and you might still
have emails of how many clinics they had
I don't okay second question do you feel
as if
the I'm just going to have to use the
word Insanity because it is um that was
created by all of this is is has got to
be a top down all of these teens they're
impressionable all of this type of stuff
this it just can't come out of nowhere
right so you know pounding and pounding
and pounding and losing school and
losing friends and losing this right so
I mean it has to come from there like
you know it has it did become every
everyone but didn't it start it had to
start from the top absolutely the
message was clear and
consistent that the world could open up
when everybody got
vaccinated and if it didn't open up
blame them ones that refused to get the
vaccine and that message was loud and
clear
um
yeah
uh any
other so all of that I mean
that kind of builds up
to the pressure that she was feeling the
stress she was feeling I didn't even
talk or mention just the whole process
to apply for colleges visiting colleges
that was a whole other experience that
we could spend a lot of time on but the
real blow for her came when she found
out that in order to go to the College
of her
choice that she needed to be
vaccinated may I ask what state that
college was in it so she looked at a
variety of colleges the one that she
chose was in
Maine um thank you
and so some of the colleges
had programs where they would um tag
your college ID and so that wherever you
swiped it whatever door whatever whether
you went to the
cafeteria it was clear and you were
supposed to be masked while unvaccinated
could not so they had different
different universities had different
approaches that they took and that was
all over the country um that wasn't just
here um she chose Maine because it was a
very strong Health Care College small it
fit what she wanted it wasn't that far
from
home um so we kept thinking that if
she if we waited and kept waiting people
would realize the data wasn't supporting
this you know there were breakthrough
cases happening everywhere so we kept
being very optimistic that eventually
they would say yeah it's okay okay um
which was very naive on my part um the
end of July my daughter went to a
freshman Camp up at the school and they
didn't require the vaccine for her to go
to that freshman Camp she lived in the
dorm she had a great time stayed up late
hanging made friends did all sorts of
things loved it um but they still were
requiring the mandate to actually go to
school in the fall
um I tried to get medical exemption but
at that time those were extremely hard
to come
by and we kept asking if we could get
one and none of her doctors nobody felt
that she had any reason not to get it if
anything they felt because of her
chronic pain condition that she should
get it I sen
Penza so I my family experienced that
too with a daughter of mine so um do you
feel as
if kind of everything that we
knew previous history all of these types
of things you know um went out the
window um even even of course kids that
had you know disabilities and stuff that
that went out the window and
because we couldn't find any doctor
anywhere
absolutely and you to even bring it up
you
were um I felt like you were treated
differently if you even brought it up um
they
so so she ended up getting it we
couldn't get the medical exemption um my
gut kept telling me not to let her get
it um I didn't think there was enough
resour SE Arch I didn't think there was
Data there wasn't um I was just afraid
of how she would react to
it um so we waited until the last
possible day August 4th
2021 two weeks before she had to go to
school we went up we got the vaccine
that morning
and stopped picked up lunch and went to
the beach to eat and she said she was
tired she wasn't feeling great she was
tired and could we just go home so we
did um we went home and she went
upstairs to lay down and about 30
minutes later she came back downstairs
and told me she wasn't feeling well she
said something's not right um she felt
like her heart was racing she was sweaty
and hot and we checked her heart rate
and it was over 180
um she was an
athlete um so I called the doctor's
office and I was told to take her
directly to the
ER um there the waiting room was full um
it was um there were people who had been
waiting for hours um but they took my
daughter straight back um they did an
EKG the EKG came back
abnormal um
and she started feeling really sick like
she was going to throw up she was very
nauseous um so they gave her medication
to try to slow her heart rate and after
they would give her the medication her
heart rate would drop for a few seconds
and then it would Elevate right back up
so they kept trying to figure out what
was happening and eventually they told
us that she was going to be admitted to
the I
you
um she didn't feel good you know
as I don't mean to interrupt you and I
am so sorry that as a
mom that you had to deal with this
issue two questions are
one um where was she vaccinated at what
vaccination did she get and I guess I do
have a third
question when you went to the ER did the
doctors there ask you if she was
vaccinated and when she received
it so your first
question because I was concerned we
actually made an appointment um at
Hutchins Memorial Hospital in wolfboro
because I wanted her not to be in a mall
or
Anna you
know yeah so that was where where I
wanted her in a hospital setting because
I was I was
concerned um the second thing she got
the Johnson and Johnson because we felt
it was one and done you know get it she
was done go to
school third
question forgive me what was your when
she was admitted to the ER did they ask
if she was vaccinated and then the
second part of that was is did they
asked when she was vaccinated
so we told them I don't think I gave
them the opportunity to ask that
question I told them as soon as we got
there that this was a vac that she had
just gotten the vaccine and that this
was happening with the vaccine um two
things is they kept testing her for
covid over and over for her entire
Hospital stay and it kept coming back
negative um um but
they that was one thing that was very
interesting um they ran a lot of blood
work and they ran a lot of different
tests and the diagnosis the immediate
diagnosis was severe
tachicardia um from induced from the
vaccine um my daughter she turned to me
and she just said Mommy I wish I didn't
get the
vaccine and am I going to be
okay
and I just kept telling her yes it's
going to be okay you know
so after they told me she was going to
the
ICU they told me because she had just
turned 18 I couldn't go up with
her
and so I ended up finally convincing
them to allow me to go up and make sure
she was settled and this is the middle
of the night now so I convinced them to
let me go up and set get her settled in
and I did and the plan was for her to
have a CT scan in the morning um they
felt like she was comfortable and you
know that she would be fine we got up to
her room in the
ICU um and we weren't even in the door
of her room and the phone was ringing
and it was the ER doctor saying they'd
gotten test results back and that she
needed to go immediately to CT for a
scan at that right then um so that they
could do a chest scan and see what was
going on they felt something was wrong
based on the blood work that they had
gotten
back
um they told me I couldn't be
there my daughter asked me if I would
stay at the hotel next to the hospital
um and
I so at that point I left um when they
brought her down to the CT and I went in
the parking lot and I sat in my car and
I
cried
um that was I was trying so hard the
whole time we were there just to be mom
and strong and so got out to the car and
I cried and I'll tell you you know it's
been really hard to forgive myself for
letting her get that
vaccine um that I didn't fight hard
enough and listen to my gut to prevent
her from H feeling that she had no other
choice but the more I look back at
this
um the more that I look back at this I'm
upset with the
system that brought this on that gave
her no
Choice um she spent 3 days in ICU and
then she spent one more in just a
regular bed and her heart rate would
spike every time she moved so her
resting heart rate over the next few
days slowly went down to 140
130 um I think they wanted it at 120 as
a resting heart rate before they would
let her go
home um she had one of her friends came
to visit and the mom called me
afterwards and said Tara she cuz she's
hooked up to all the monitors and
everything and she
said my daughter said anytime Abby moved
all her like just adjusting in bed her
heart rate would spike just a simple
thing sit up in your chair heart rate
would spike machines go off and so it
took you know that was what she was
dealing with um so when we brought her
home she was dizzy exhausted nauseous
and she kept saying her heart hurt she
kept saying her chest her heart it hurt
but there was nothing wrong no answers
Tac cardia um at one point I believe we
were told
that it was like she'd run a marathon
for
days and that she was healthy and fit
which is what allowed her to run that
Marathon for
days um and so that might be why it
hurtt um
so we got home and my
husband um let me back up for a minute
here and catch my thoughts um I think I
mentioned that I'm a little bit upset
with the system that created this
environment uh one thing I wanted to say
is I felt they harassed her and they
bullied her um um in so many different
ways into getting an experimental
unproven
vaccine in order to be able to live her
life for 18 months covid was held over
her head as to why she couldn't do
anything then the covid vaccine was held
over her head if she wanted to have the
future that she wanted went from covid
being held can't do anything because of
Co to now you can't do anything because
you're not vaccinated
um at this point we had the knowledge
the data that covid wasn't impacting our
youth
severely um we had the information we
knew many many vaccinated in individuals
who were getting covid with breakthrough
infections
um when we came home from the
hospital my husband would carry her up
and down the stairs
um
so every night we'd carry her up every
morning we'd bring her
down
um we got a stool for the shower so that
she could take showers um so we did
everything we could to make her
comfortable and let her lead her
life um she lost 20
lbs um she's 5'2 and she weighed 110 PBS
uh so she dropped down to 90 lbs she
couldn't eat she felt horrible and
despite all of that she somehow managed
to go to school that first
semester um we didn't want to take that
away from her my husband and I went
round and round on whether or not we let
her go to school we talked to the school
we got
accommodations um she would get hot
flashes and so they let us put an air
conditioner in her
room um we simplified her schedule so it
was the bare
basic um bare minimum so that she could
try to have that college
experience um they ended up moving her
to a single room uh just because she
needed to rest so
often um and it was just she's 18 and
this is how her college experience
started um that first semester was
filled with doctor's appointments we
would drive back and forth my husband
and I to pick her up and bring her down
and then bring her back back um just do
whatever we could so that she could be
at College have that but still get the
treatment that she needed and she she
wanted the social she wanted to be there
um she tells me now that she doesn't
remember very much about her freshman
semester which doesn't surprise me at
all um I will never forget one call that
I got from her and a friend of hers uh
her heart hurt really bad and her friend
said she looks green she doesn't look
good something's not right um she was
dizzy nauseous and they didn't know what
to
do and she told me she thought she was
having a heart
attack so we went to the ER um they did
an EKG said everything looked normal and
S
home
um really nobody knew what was
happening and my perception and my
feeling was that when they heard this
was a vaccine
injury I felt like people didn't want to
be involved with
it um so we had no answers we had no it
was this is she'll get better or we
don't know we don't have have any
answers for you um so that was her
freshman year um we she decided and we
decided she would not go back to school
in the
spring um she kept we kept her home to
try and heal and we did get some
answers um in addition to tac cardia she
has
pots um and
gastroparesis so her pots uh which is
postoral orthostatic tacac cardia
syndrome that's being treated by a
neurologist with a medication that she
takes three times a day um and that has
helped her with some of the dizziness
and some of those symptoms and her heart
rate
fluctuation uh her gastroparesis is
being treated by a gastron neurologist
with medication that she takes
daily that medication cost 600 plus a
month um and a few weeks ago her
insurance declined it um after two years
of being on it it was
declined and so we went back and forth
we finally got to the point where
she said I was getting texts from her
and calls from her and she find she's
like Mom I'm nauseous my stomach hurts I
can't eat I've lost weight
again so I said I'm going to pick the
medication up right now now it doesn't
matter what it costs you need
it
thankfully the insurance approved it
that
day um so that was two days ago and so
she is starting to feel a little bit
better now
fortunately um so
unfortunately it showed us that she's
still dealing with these health issues
they haven't gone
away um
does she need to be on these medications
the rest of her life I don't know um I
hope not I hope we can find a way to get
her off from them I hope we can find a
way to help figure out what's causing
the pain in her chest um she'll still
have that and nobody knows what causes
that um we've just been to so many
doctors appointments therapy we've gone
a uh different types of doctors as well
um because a lot of the treatments
aren't covered by insurance if you want
to have um acupuncture or if you want to
have
IVs um to try to help rebalance the body
um getting some of the blood work done
is not something that most doctors will
order so we've gone to different um
individuals to try to get additional
answers um that we haven't been able to
get through traditional doctors and that
we all we pay for out of pocket um she
has been through so much and yet
she continues to always have a smile and
a positive
attitude um currently she's in the
process finishing up her junior year in
college and looking at graduate programs
to continue on to the medical field um
she still wants to go to the medical
field and help people
um she has a medical exemption for all
vaccines going forward and she also has
a permanent handicap placard um as
well we were
told that not having a vaccine may
impact her ability to get clinicals and
graduate and graduate from
school interesting thing right now
unfortunately even even though medical
professionals no longer are required to
get the vaccine covid vaccine and even
though schools many colleges no longer
mandate the covid
vaccine there is a group of people that
are still being
pressured and required to get that and
that is our college students who want to
go into the medical
professional and what they hold over
their head is the inability to get
clinicals or
rotations and you need to provide your
vaccination status in
order to get those rotations and those
clinicals so forgive me for my ignorance
here um but if she's already been
vaccinated with with the J&J which was a
oneandone why would she be denied
clinicals because she is vaccinated so
the j& J she is vaccinated on what she
is not now because she has a medical
waiver for all she is not vaccinated for
the flu um she is
also had to do a tighter test for
hepatitis B I believe it
was and even though she had when she was
very
young three I believe it was three doses
of the Hep B I believe it's Hep B um
vaccine her tighter test came back that
she had
zero
particles of That vaccine so she is
completely
unprotected and therefore she also needs
to get the he B
vaccine
so yes she is considered vaccinated for
covid now there are other medical
students who are
not um I had an opportunity to meet a
couple of wonderful gentlemen who are in
a nursing
program and they went
down I can't I think they went to
Liberty
College because it was the only place
that they knew they could get
clinicals so even
today this is still
being um
um I don't know how to phrase this but
it's
still
impacting students who want to go into
the medical Fields because they have to
provide their vaccination
statuses and it may not allow them to
get the clinicals and the rotations that
they
need represent
Penza go going back to when she first
was in the hospital can you do you mind
saying where she first was with her um
like where she like where she went when
she stayed when she was in ICU where
those were she was in exitor hos
hospital did she ever go any other place
outside of exitor not not for that
hospital stay no okay um for
subsequent um any other she has gone to
the ER in Portsmith she has gone to
Boston children that's what I she has
gone to Mass General okay she has gone
to she had a team of four neurologist
one was a um the autonomic dysfunction
neurologist one was the gastro
neurologist one was
a movement specialist
because her chronic pain has gone into
severe pain a severe Flare from all of
this um she's not been able to
walk
um so she sees a movement disorder
specialist and she sees a pain
management specialist as well are those
all out out of Massachusetts no she goes
to Dover which is affiliated with Mass
General yeah Mass so it's a bit of a mix
it's a bit of a mix of where she goes
yeah thank you
y
um as a
mom looking
back is there anything that you feel
that the state should have done
differently anything going forward that
we should be looking
at um and any suggestions for anything
in the future that may come down the
pike um just want to see what your ideas
are or your opinions um if you don't
mind no that's
um yeah um I mean in terms of what the
state could have been done
differently at the beginning there was
this fear of the death rate was
supposedly so high on this um on covid
when it first came out and that that
scared
everybody but I think once that
information and the data started coming
out and it was
available I think there was a concerted
lack of effort
to share that um one thing I'd like to
say also is and I I haven't even talked
about the censoring that went on um I
brought a
post that my daughter
made
because two months after she
was after her vaccine
injury she wanted to share because
nobody understood why she was so
physically depleted up there and she
wanted them to know this isn't me you
know this and all she kept hearing was
vaccine vaccine vaccine that was still
being pushed everywhere so she made a
post and I'm going to read exactly what
she wrote um this is not a post I would
typically make but I feel compelled to
share my story I am not antivaccine but
I do believe in medical Freedom as
people know their body best I got the
covid vaccine in early August and that
night I was admitted to the ICU two
months later I'm still dealing with side
effects everyone including medical
professionals disregarded my concerns
due to my underlying
conditions which was that pain condition
that she had they all told me to get the
shot and they wouldn't give me a medical
waiver after my reaction everyone says I
should have gotten a medical waiver but
by then it was too late it makes me sad
to see the level of anger and pressure
towards people who are remaining
unvaccinated when no one except them
knows their particular
situation please have compassion and
understanding that people are doing the
best they can with the information that
is out there she made this post on
October 21st of
2021 and I she included a picture of
herself in the hospital
bed what you might probably can't see
from where you're sitting is that post
was tagged by
Instagram co9 vaccines go through many
tests for safety and Effectiveness and
are then monitored closely Source World
Health
Organization she was not able to share
her story without it being tagged
Facebook support groups that I was part
of for vaccine injured would get shut
down there
posts
removed comments
tagged there was a degree of information
that we were not even allowed to share
what happened to her with
anybody and I the interesting thing is I
went back last night
the tag is now
removed so it's no longer important for
them to share that information now but
it was when my daughter posted about
that vaccine and the reason I share that
is because I think in my heart I feel
like that is important to
understand what she was going through it
represents just a small piece of what
she had to deal with when she spoke to
people about her vaccine
injury and I'll tell you I
had I had a close friend of ours so
immediately after it we focused on our
health but then it didn't take us long
to realize that people really didn't
want to hear about her vaccine injury
because that was the that made people
uncomfortable because everything they
heard up to that point safe and
effective it's all safe and effective so
one close friend of ours actually
suggested to
me couple of days after Abby got home
from the hospital that I should feel
better now that she was vaccinated and
could prevent PE other people from
getting
covid I had another woman tell me
vaccine injuries are rare and that a
certain rate of severe injuries was was
okay in her mind for the better of the
rest of the
population
so this is what we would we were going
through on top of trying to heal I also
wrote letters
to um I
wrote I've got two more topics that I
really want to talk about one is the
letters that I wrote to our Senators and
the other one is about our V's
experience um so I wrote letters because
I felt like we weren't hearing anything
so I sent those emails and a staffer
from either Maggie Hassen or jeene
Shaheen's office I cannot remember which
office it was called me quite some time
after I'd sent the letter to
them and they called
me because they wanted to ensure me that
the senator was working diligently to
ensure everyone was vaccinated in a
timely
manner they had a canned speech prepared
for me that had nothing to do with my
email or what happened to my
daughter the only commonality was that
it was vaccine
related so I explained my purpose for
reaching out to them and they said they
couldn't answer my questions and offer
to have someone else call me I then got
a senior staffer who reached out who
then explained to me how rare these
injuries were they were sorry for my
daughter um and that unfortunately my
daughter was just a casualty for the
greater good of the
population I then asked if these vaccine
reactions were so rare why had no one
reached out to us from the CDC from
Johnson and Johnson from the government
from
anybody why had no one wanted to learn
what might have triggered this reaction
in my daughter that was so
rare Why did no one want to learn that
the other thing
was or was it that they just didn't
care represented
Penza um
first question is in in regards with um
I know what you're talking about with
the form letter multiple times I can't
tell you how many people tell us the
same thing it's like it's not even read
and it's just an instant response which
is it's like adding gasoline to a fire I
get it um
locally um I've heard from many
constituents um that there was never a
response from our governor that that was
on every so you didn't hear back from
that office at all no correct okay no I
guess the question is as you reached out
to the US senators but no one in the
state government I I did I I blanketed a
lot of emails um but the only person I
heard back from was that one Senator's
office okay thank you yeah
representative
beler thank you madam chair and thank
you for being here I'm sure this has not
been easy
um now I I certainly wouldn't presume to
estimate what the mechanism of injury
your daughter may have experienced was
but given the sort of the the rapidity
or the acute onset of of some of the
issues I would ask because this is
something we we uh heard about before
lunch um I would ask if you
aware that guidelines for how vaccines
were to be administered was ch
changed um in the leadup to
covid-19 such that previously um and I
was a healthc care provider for quite a
long time so previously we were taught
when administering an intramuscular
vaccine you insert the serin you're the
needle into the into the deltoid muscle
group and you pull back a little on the
plunger to see if you're you if you get
blood you would indicate you're in a
blood vessel and you cannot
inject um before lunch we heard from a a
gentleman
an almost unbelievable story about the
CDC changing their guidelines away from
aspiration solely for the cause of it
might be more painful if you aspirate so
I actually went on and I pulled this
this pink uh book that he told us about
and I'd like to just read briefly from
it because I couldn't believe it
myself aspiration is not recommended
before administering a vaccine
aspiration prior to injecting and
injecting medication slowly are
practices that have not been evaluated
scientifically aspiration was originally
recommended for theoretical safety
reasons and injecting medication slowly
was thought to decrease pain from Sudden
distension of muscle tissue aspiration
can increase pain because of the
combined effects of a longer needle
dwelling time in the tissues and
shearing action wiggling of the needle
it it is exactly what was described
before launch that for some reason
despite not citing any medical evidence
uh that it was safe to make this change
it was simply less painful in theory
they would no longer aspirate to see if
they were in a blood vessel before
injecting is that something you were
aware of I was not aware that they had
changed the policies however my sister
is an RN and we had had conversations
about the method of
injections um after all of this and she
was had told me about aspiration and um
how she used to always deliver
injections but I was not aware thank you
because the official recommendation for
the method to deliver the covid-19
vaccines was to deliver them rapidly and
without
aspiration with as far as I can tell no
scientific backing
for possibly injecting these into an
artery or a vein do you have a date on
which that policy changed by any chance
uh I I'll look at this to see if I can
find a date on it this is the pink sheet
PDF I'm looking at from the CDC website
um but I I don't know the date but I'll
look for it okay thank you represent
Penza so I had a question I know you're
going to talk about it um in regards
with theirs so um as you I'm sure of B
well aware the the percentage is is
extremely high like I I I don't even
know at this point 90% probably that
they're not doctors nurses medical
they're just not trained in even knowing
how to report it's very cumbersome all
of that kind of stuff so when you knew
because you knew right away that this
was a vaccine injury did you ask um did
you ask the doctor was this at the ER
did you who did you ask and how did that
process work when you said this needed
to re be reported to vs so when all of
this happened I wasn't thinking about
anything but my daughter it wasn't until
after she was home and later
on um that I some someone I mentioned
said have you made sure this is reported
they then told me that I wanted to make
sure that it was reported by The
Physician and not
self-reported due to the weight that it
carried when a physician reported it
versus self-reporting
so I called the hospital to see if it
was reported and it took 10 different
phone
calls um before I got to somebody um
many of the people that I spoke with
didn't even know what theirs was um they
had no idea who was responsible for
entering it into the V system I finally
got put in touch with the director of
infectious
diseases at exitor hospital and at after
looking into it he agreed to enter it
himself um he was not her physician he
had never met her however he agreed to
enter it in since nobody they had no
idea who should do it um so he actually
entered the data in and he sent me the
v's ID
number so when I then looked up the v's
ID number to make sure the information
was accurate and entered correctly
um you all can imagine how I felt when
the number that was given to me pulled
up a woman in her late 20s who had
experienced a reaction a reaction to the
flu vaccine years
ago rather than my
daughter so I reached back out to the
director and I explained what I was
seeing and I asked confirmed did you
send me the right number because
something isn't a in here and he goes
yeah he goes I entered it myself I got
the number and he pulled it up for
himself and he goes Tara I'm seeing
exactly what you're seeing and he goes I
don't know what
happened um I entered the data myself
this isn't
right at this point I'll be honest I
gave
up um
I I threw my hands up in the air because
what can you do how far can you push
this um so that's when I started writing
to all of our elected officials um
because I'm
like you know what what where can I take
this the hospital I'm at the director of
the and
nobody like nobody seems to
care represent
Potenza I don't know if you real I mean
I'm not sure you do how huge that is
like that is the that is humongous so if
if you have on on record um and if you
can get on
record the date that was entered you
know um the director of infectious
disease and everything that he put in
and he States through like a sworn
Affidavit of this and then what is what
is presented this is humongous so I
texted
back and forth with him we were on a
text basis and I um unfortunately my my
phone dropped to the bottom of the lake
oh my God but I've also had emails and I
will look and see if I can find those
specific things but his response back to
me Tara I'm seeing exactly what you're
seeing I actually wrote reached out
um last year last last fall early this
year I can't remember but I spoke with
um representative Eric tur he is the
brenwood
representative and he has spent
substantial amount of time looking into
this and he's talked
to I don't know director of New
Hampshire Health and Human Services and
he said he was he so he was doing
research and looking into what happened
um as well so it might be worthwhile to
follow up with definely could you repeat
which representative that was it was
Eric tur
t r from Brentwood New Hampshire okay
okay um also um would you mind leaving
the information that you have so we can
put it in our files that you brought um
for our records and if you could locate
any emails regarding the theirs data yep
that would
be
extremely
helpful um for this committee I mean I
can't even imagine as a mom what you're
still going through um I'm sure it's a
living nightmare every day
um and out of curiosity has your
daughter been able to connect with any
other injured vacine injured people um
for
support so
I'd have to follow back up with her on
that um she has a close friend who was
um injured by the HPV
vaccine um but I don't know as she's got
someone that she's directly connecting
with over the covid there have been
support
groups one thing I would say is when I
was on a lot of those support groups
some of them got shut down
and and may I ask were those like on
Facebook they were on Facebook and they
were were shut down yeah so going back
to your question earlier about you know
future and what we can
do that's why I brought up you know the
blocks that we ran into and why we felt
nobody cared and our Voice couldn't be
heard
um people we know other individuals who
were injured by the covid
vaccine a lot of them don't want to
speak
out um may I ask wh why do you feel that
they don't want to speak out I I guess I
mean are they embarrassed are they
confused um do they feel uh they'll be
uh stigmatized I mean I can't speak for
recently but I can speak for when this
first happened
we lost
friends
um over my daughter getting injured by
the
vaccine you know it was a taboo
subject people didn't want to hear it
because it made it
real I don't I can't tell you why I
think some of it was fear I think some
of it was you
know it got to a point where you like
just us trying to share information you
would get
tagged um misinformation
or
guidance um you so I I don't have a
great answer for you on it all I know
is
I I can't not speak up and as my
daughter says she doesn't want to have
what happened to her ever happened to
anybody
else um well I I can't tell you how
appreciative I am and
um that you've come before here and I'm
sure that it's taken a lot uh to come
and talk about this um representative
Penza and then representative I mean
representative poitz and then
representative belad
oh it's not
working hit another one
maybe give them yours uh
oh I'm sorry for what you experienced
and that the state failed to deliver
accurate information but thank you for
sharing it with us and fighting for your
daughter and for other daughters and as
her injury happened in
2021 and in
2023 State
epidemiologist Dr Benjamin Chan uh
testified in state house uh uh that
covid vaccines are safe but he did
recognize that there's some increase in
my my carditis but mostly in boys my
young
males and uh uh if it's too personal you
don't have to answer but my
understanding is your daughter is not
was not born as a boy so do you know
like uh if
uh if other women were uh if there are
other women who were injured by by this
uh uh covid vaccine uh
yes um as a matter of
fact after what happened to my daughter
I was talking to the mother of one of
her classmates from her Elementary
School
suy um so SE is not a huge school but
there was a another girl who went to
school with
Abby and had to get the vaccine for
college same thing
and she ended up being rushed to the
hospital afterwards with very similar um
the rapid heart rate not feeling well um
the same day that she had gotten her
vaccine we also know of another
individual who lost the feeling in her
legs after the
vaccine
um and I don't know the status of that
person
now we also know
um someone else whose diabetes went out
of control
after so there were numerous and it
seems Now everywhere we go people are
now ready to share a little bit more
about their experience and what happened
to them after it um but back in
2021 it was not a subject that we
discussed represent beler thank you
madam chair and thank you again um so I
I can I can speak to the veracity of
many of the things you've said because I
too have experienced them I was fairly
significantly injured um after an mRNA
vaccine I uh to had the distinct
impression sometimes that when some
healthcare providers would learn that I
was a vaccine injury patient their
attitude would shift significantly
yeah I too
experienced uh censorship when I
attempted to tell about what had
happened to me uh my social media
accounts were suspended I was not able
to access them um now I'm a little
little bit older uh it irritated me to
no end being censored but it didn't
devastate me to lose my social media
Accounts at the time now younger people
are much more tied in on social media I
can only imagine that that experience
for them to lose access to their friends
and their primary means of communication
I expect in many cases would be much
more traumatic than it was for me so I
guess my question for you is do you
think that the censorship that did exist
around this losing access to social
media because she simply tried to tell
her friends in the world what had
happened what her experience was um do
you believe that that contributed to a
sort of environment of um of trying to
of trying to prevent people from talking
or or keeping people from talk speaking
out about about their situation yeah so
I guess first of all um I'll be clear my
daughter never lost access to her social
media um but she was hesitant on what to
post and when she finally did post they
tagged it
um she I think that definitely made her
hesitant to share anymore um I know as
an adult with it it made me hesitant to
want to share
information um and I know a lot of other
people were hesitant to share or speak
out
because
of the
perception there was a narrative in my
opinion in my personal opinion there
were certain things you were allowed to
say and you were not allowed to say
talking about vaccine injuries and harm
from vaccines was not
allowed represent
Elizabeth uh it's not a question more a
comment to committee I agree that we
need to look look what happens uh with
uh virus database but I heard from
reputable sources that they have double
numeration so there's like not a single
number but there are two sets of number
and when report is uh
submitted people receive one number but
then when database is squared is it's
different set of numbers so they don't
much and uh there were some other cases
when it was causing a confusion so not
saying it should be this way but there
might be some explanation to it besides
like
uh uh just something we need to consider
thank you
representative does anyone else have any
other
questions
um again I just want to say thank you so
much is there anything else you'd like
to add or that you would want to say to
this committee or I think the last two
things kind of and I appreciate you
having me tell talk through what
happened with our family um I think the
other things that I'd like to share is
from my husband um this morning the one
thing he wanted me to make sure sure
everybody
heard
was before our daughter received the
vaccine everybody cared about her
vaccine
status after she got her vaccine and was
injured nobody cared about her vaccine
injury and
that you know you couldn't go to
restaurants you museums
people wanted vaccine ID cards maybe not
here in the state of New Hampshire some
did some did um nobody cared
um so the second thing is just going
back to what the state should look into
never let these School schools close
down these kids should never have been
removed from school and not allowed to
have have that education and that social
interaction we harmed our
children so much more um and it never
should have lasted as long as it
did
um the be
system it it's not it doesn't
work uh represent PS off then
representative Penza
thank you uh thank you for taking my
other question and if it's to personal
don't answer but like we are often told
that as as as you were explained that
it's for the better good and some small
cases happen and we are told that uh
there's a special fund created by
government that compensate in cases of
vaccine injury I'm here that it's almost
impossible to get that compensation and
it expires quite quickly in couple years
so did you ever tried did you ever get
anything well first there was a lot of
misinformation um provided in terms of
what you could and couldn't do at least
to me the second thing was by the
time there was one policy that was not
covid vaccines were not eligible for and
then the other one that you could be
eligible for expired I believe it was
one year after the date of
vaccination but it was a minimum amount
and because my student was a college age
student she didn't have loss or I mean a
high school student she didn't have loss
of income and her health insurance
covered bills so she didn't have
anything to go ask for from that and
then it expired within a year so by the
time we learned about it even to look
into to it she wasn't eligible anymore
um but no there's there nobody's been
held accountable or
helped
um from that standpoint yeah thank you
represent
Venza so I'm I'm trying to find the
article and my computer's about to die
so I'm not going to be able to um so
there was just a it was recent it's got
to be in maybe the last week or two um
I'm not sure if it's a if it's a
pharmaceutical company I think it might
be could be fizer possibly or if it was
the CDC but so in addition of theirs I'm
sure you're familiar with there were
there's was a couple different Avenues
right so a manufacturers were taking in
um uh
injuries uh reports uh CDC was taking in
a piece of those as well and then of
course the cumbers ve system and which
is very EAS um hard for people to like
get data from and all of that kind of
stuff so they just released uh one
pharmaceutical company just were forced
to compelled by the government to
release the level of like calls and all
of that kind of stuff for injuries are
you familiar with that I'm not okay so
I'd love to I'm going to find that
information and and get that to you
um I would love to have our committee
follow up with any pieces to have your
story and um and to see whatever we can
do within our power to make sure um that
there's that there's things that are
held accountable um especially timelines
with the school and and that's extremely
important to me
um yeah I can't even imagine the level
of medical bills and all of that other
kind of stuff that have that have
surmounted in this in this whole thing
but I'd also love to help you with a
whole community of of folks as well
because I I really think that they the
voices are there some people are scared
um but it needs to come out but the
community is Big we're kind of our own
family so my daughter's vaccine injured
so listening to you I just I just want
to cry I was crying pretty much half the
time so there's there's a lot of them a
lot of but it just there needs to
be a bigger voice an official voice
and we need to look at everything and
make sure we don't run into this covid
experience again it needs to be handled
better
um uh and that is the mission of this
committee is to see what we got right
what we got wrong um going forward and
again I cannot tell you how much we
really appreciate hearing from you and
you having the courage to come and tell
your story thank so thank thank you so
much thank you and if you could uh if
you find those emails yes um would
greatly appreciate uh that if I will
look for the school emails and I'll look
for the documentation and the screenshot
I took of the vs okay that would be
awesome so thank you so much thank
you okay so um for the rest of us is
there anything that we need to discuss
at the moment uh currently it looks like
our next meeting will probably be April
26th I'm hoping to hear from director
buckton I'm not sure yet um uh don't
have any speakers lined up at the moment
to represent
beler thank Madam chair just just a
question because we we talked this
morning first we opened up with some
possibly some brainstorming for some
questions to DHS do we shall we just
simply forward whatever we have to you
uh yes please and if you have any uh
questions that you want to direct to uh
Homeland Security also um to forward
those also to me um because in looking
at the email that
um representative eel read this morning
you know she talked about how they also
handled part of the financial portions
uh some of the federal monies regarding
the rollout um so it looks like they had
a pretty big hand in
things um so yes if anyone has any
questions if you could forward them to
me I will forward them them on to the
appropriate agencies uh representative
eel did ask uh for a for me to email the
questions that I sent off to uh Patricia
Tilly I will forward that email I will
forward those questions to everyone so
that you can see the questions that I
sent to her I also let her know that all
those questions may not be under her
perview and if they were not uh if she
could direct us to the appropriate
person
um so is there anything else that uh we
need to discuss or that any needs
anything that needs to be ritten to the
record at this
time seeing nothing I will close the
meeting and
uh we'll probably meet on April 26th and
I will try and make it at 10:00
a.m. everyone
enjoy for